Herzlich Willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 38.
Jawohl.
Und wir müssen heute glaube ich mal ein wenig über die Apokalypse reden.
Ja, also es hat uns so ein bisschen eingeholt. Und wir dachten, wir können vielleicht gemeinsam hier so eine Art Selbsthilfegruppe gründen.
Die postapokalypse Zombieapokalypse Überstehungselfhilfegruppe.
Na die Frage hat sich ja schon länger gegründet. Wir haben ja mit Rob mal auf dem Camp diese tolle Sendung gemacht, die auch sehr gut angekommen ist. So die war so ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, konkreter. Nach dem Motto, welche Bunker werden wann Typen sich eignen für welches szenario. Und schon damals hat sich ja eigentlich die Frage gestellt, ab wann wir denn jetzt eigentlich ausrufen, dass die Apokalypse da ist. Und ich denke jetzt nach Trump ist ein guter Moment.
Ich glaube, es ist noch zu früh.
Ja?
Ja. Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass Trump möglicherweise weniger schlecht wird, als wir es alle erwarten. Ich glaube nur, er wird anders schlecht, als wir es erwarten. Also wir bewegen uns halt in einer Zeit, wo Vorhersagen über die Zukunft eigentlich nicht mehr möglich sind. Wo wir also nicht mehr in der Lage sind, zu sagen, der wird sich so und so verhalten oder auch nur dessen Interessen oder deren Interessen sind so und so. Deswegen werden sich so und so verhalten.
Und zwar schon für die nahe Zukunft. So nächste Woche geht es schon nicht mehr.
Genau. Das hat so alles völlig nonlinear geworden so. Und das ist halt eine Sache, die relativ verwirrend ist, weil natürlich ist es einfach jetzt halt zu sagen, also okay, Amerika wird im Faschismus versinken. Offener Rassismus wird irgendwie die Vereinigten Staaten regieren. Die werden ihren, ihre Mauer bauen und so weiter. Also quasi das gesamte Trump-Programm wortwörtlich zu nehmen und nach vorne zu extrapolyieren, ist natürlich eine Möglichkeit, sich auf die Zukunft vorzubereiten. Sie hat den großen Vorteil, dass man, wenn man das annimmt, natürlich irgendwie auf das Allerschlimmste vorbereitet ist mental. Also es ist halt so die apokalyptische Aufschrei auf der liberalen Linken über dieses Wahlergebnis. Hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass, wenn es jetzt nicht ganz so schlimm kommt, dann können sich sogar fast noch ein bisschen freuen. Hingegen machen sich halt keine illusionen darüber, was halt passiert, wie es halt auch kommen kann. Und was wir halt schon deutlich sehen, ist ja ein dramatischer Anstieg von rassistischer Gewalt, von Altersassismus, von, naja, sag mal, Leuten, die ziemlich lange in ihrem Kämmerlein waren und da halt irgendwie ihre Nazi-Flagge irgendwie an der Wand hatten und sich jetzt halt an die Öffentlichkeit trauen und glauben, dass sie halt die neuen Herren sind. So und das ist halt natürlich ein Punkt, wo man schon halt irgendwie ernsthaft Angst bekommen kann, insbesondere wenn man halt irgendwie jetzt nicht, ja, unbedingt irgendwie zu denen gehört, die in den USA besondern sind irgendwie privilegiert und irgendwie gut angesehen sind. Und daraus folgt natürlich jetzt halt auch eine relativ apokalyptische Welt sich zu. Also die von Leuten, die jetzt einfach sagen, okay, wir müssen hier weg, geht nicht mehr an.
Also ich finde die diskussion deswegen ausgesprochen spannend gerade, weil Trumps Wahlprogramm eben so, wie soll ich sagen, unkonkret ist. Der hat sich im Grunde zu jedem Thema in alle Richtungen irgendwann mal geäußert. Das heißt, Voraussagen, die jetzt die Apokalypse annehmen, die picken sich halt da die Aussagen raus, die auf eine Apokalypse hindeuten. Aber es gibt eben auch jeweils in die andere Richtung Aussagen von Trump. Das macht es so ein bisschen schwierig. Ist wie so ein Wackelpudding, den du an die Wand nageln willst. Da kannst du immer, wenn du irgendwie glaubst, du hast einen Punkt erwischt, dann twittert er schon wieder das Gegenteil. Trump ist so ein bisschen, das ist auch ein Mechanismus, auf den wir gleich nochmal in Ruhe eingehen werden. Aber worüber wir also eigentlich reden wollen, ist gar nicht die konkrete Ausprägung des Chaos in Sachen Trump, sondern dieser generelle Trend, dass die Welt plötzlich aussieht, als würden unsere Modelle nicht mehr fitten. Wir haben ja alle irgendwie ein Modell, wie die Welt funktioniert und das passt nicht mehr. Und das ist teilweise, liegt das daran, dass unser Modell scheiße ist, aber teilweise ist es auch aktiv herbeigeführt. Ich muss ja sagen, ich fühl mich persönlich gut vorbereitet auf die Trump-Ebene, eher ihrer.
Durch deine ausführliche Lektüre von Reddit?
Durch Rollenspiele hab ich in Shadowrun und in anderer dystopischer Sci-Fi-Literatur genau gelesen, was jetzt passiert. Jetzt kommt die Trolle aus ihren, also die tatsächlich Trolle bei Shadowrun, gibt es tatsächlich Trolle. Und Orks und Elfen und so und die Magie kehrt zurück. Aber abgesehen von dem Teil gibt es eben Vorhersagen, die durchaus jetzt alle passieren könnten. Teilweise schon passiert sind. Insofern ist für mich sehr faszinierend, dass plötzlich, also ich will es mal so ausdrücken, bisher fühlte sich das Leben so ein bisschen an wie eine Eisenbahn. Man weiß eigentlich grob, wo es hingeht. Also man weiß nicht, wie schnell es geht, aber man ist eigentlich der offene Horizont ist nicht sehr offen, sondern es gibt halt die Richtung, in die wir fahren. Und plötzlich haben wir, naja, das kann man jetzt Chaos nennen, aber man kann es auch Freiheit nennen oder Gelegenheit, ja. Wir haben plötzlich, plötzlich ist der Himmel offen und wir haben kaum noch Haltepunkte.
Also ich glaube, die Analogie passt nicht so ganz für mich.
Nein, aber...
Also es ist schon so, es gab halt relativ, bisher relativ schmales Band an Möglichkeiten, aber es war halt irgendwie nicht so ganz klar, ob es nach unten oder nach oben geht. Und was wir jetzt haben ist halt irgendwie, dieses Band an Möglichkeiten verbreitert sich, aber es geht relativ klar nach unten.
Es geht relativ klar nach unten, das stimmt. Und auf der anderen Seite kann man das auch wie ein Ökonom sehen, als die gesehen haben, es geht nach unten. Also viele Jahre haben Ökonomen immer auf Investment gezockt. Die haben halt Aktien gekauft und wenn das Unternehmen nach oben ging, haben sie wieder verkauft. Und als klar war, Aktien gehen auch mal nach unten, auch mal viele Aktien und auch mal auf längere Sicht. Dann haben sie halt angefangen Casino zu bauen, wo man auf sinkende Aktien zocken kann. Und das ist ihnen von vielen Leuten übel genommen worden. Aber ich finde, das ist auch ein gutes Zeichen, dass man nicht einfach sagt, okay, das ist alles scheiße, ich stürze mich jetzt von der Brücke. Sondern man kann es auch unter widrigsten Umständen noch als Gelegenheit sehen. Denn jetzt, wenn es mehr Chaos gibt, gibt es eben auch mehr Möglichkeiten bei Leuten, die bisher alles alternativlos genannt haben und einfach durchgemacht haben. Da gibt es jetzt plötzlich einen Hebel, den man ansetzen kann.
Die Öffnung geht halt in beide Richtungen. Momentan ist es ja nicht so, dass der eher positive, liberal eingestellte Teil der Gesellschaft da gerade Oberwasser hat. Sondern wir sehen ja eher, dass die Leute, die xenophobisch eingestellt sind, die eher eine geschlossene Gesellschaft wollen, die eher den autoritären Staat wünschen, dass die eher Oberwasser haben und sich für die halt eben die Möglichkeit zur Ausnutzung ergibt.
Ich will das gar nicht in Abrede stellen, das stimmt. Allerdings kann man das auch so erklären, dass die halt ihr Momentum noch hatten. Wir haben vor der Wahl zwei Leute gehabt oder vor der Brexit-Abstimmung oder vor egal welchen, was man jetzt konkret nimmt als Entscheidungspunkt. Da haben wir ja zwei Gruppen, die gegeneinander stehen, inhaltlich. Und die eine gewinnt, und das war jetzt eben ein paar mal die mit den negativen Aspekten. Und die haben dann nach der Wahl natürlich erst mal einen Impuls, den sie noch der Trägheit folgend weitermachen. Das heißt aber nicht, dass die langfristig gewinnen. Es kann auch passieren, dass die Leute, die jetzt verloren haben, sagen, okay, dann brauchen wir jetzt hier, warum müssen wir mehr Krafteinwirkungen, müssen wir mehr Drehmoment auf die Straße bringen. Das kann auch heißen, dass das die Gegenseite energisiert. Weiß man nicht, aber wo ich mich jetzt halt gegen wehren will, ist, dass man jetzt sagt, okay, wir haben nicht nur verloren, sondern wir sind jetzt alle tot. Wir sind zu gut im Tod.
Da stimme ich auch nicht überein, aber was du ja so ein bisschen artikulierst, ist ja quasi diese These von der notwendigen Verschärfung der Umstände als notwendige Voraussetzung dafür, dass es irgendwie besser wird.
Die halte ich auch nicht für völlig vonhandgewiesen, auch wenn ich die jetzt gar nicht meinte. Aber stimmt, das gibt da einen über einen Punkt. Naja, aber ich meine, das hat ja schon Marius gesagt. Also das ist nicht...
Leninismus.
Leninismus, okay. Aber das würde ich jetzt... Ich weiß nicht, gibt es da irgendwie Argumente, die dagegen sprechen?
Ja. Hat noch nicht funktioniert. Also tatsächlich war es so, dass die...
Frank, jetzt wollte ich hier gerade ein bisschen gute Laune verbreiten. Schon wieder alles scheiße.
Nee, also tatsächlich war es halt eine Idee von Lenin, die von Stadien halt irgendwie zur Doctrine erhoben wurde. Aber gut, also der... Natürlich kann es halt sein. Also es ist schon so, dass natürlich die, wenn die Umstände halt schlechter werden, dann raufen sich die Leute zusammen. Insbesondere, wenn man sich halt die Wahlergebnisse in Amiland anguckt, sind die ja eigentlich, insbesondere was das Popular-Vot angeht, halt jetzt schon so, dass man sagen kann, okay, dieses Land ist nicht komplett wahnsinnig geworden. Allerdings, wenn man halt zum Beispiel Kalifornien rausrechnet aus den USA, dann sieht das halt schon wieder anders aus. Also ist halt so ein, also diese zwei millionen Stimmen-Mehrheit für Hillary sind halt genau wie die Abstimmung Kalifornien. Ja, also das kann man halt genau sagen, das ist halt Kalifornien.
Ja, aber das ist keine, das ist keine sinnvolle Aussage. Das kannst du genauso gut irgendwie, kannst auch in New York, da lag Hillary weit vorne. Und wenn du New York rausnimmst, aber das ist nicht die Wahl ohne New York oder ohne Kalifornien.
Ja, das geht in Kalifornien mittlerweile anders.
Die Kalifornier denken jetzt über Absplitten nach, aber das ist, glaube ich, auch nicht die richtige Entscheidung. Also ich muss sagen, ich finde persönlich auch Zeiten interessanter für mich, wo ich das Gefühl habe, es gibt mehr.
Du kennst doch den Altdienst.
Genau, mögest du in interessanten Zeiten leben. Ich finde, wir leben in sehr interessanten Zeiten.
Irgendjemand muss uns sehr effektiv verflucht haben.
Ja, aber ich mein, also selbst, selbst wenn ich dir jetzt zustimmen würde, was ich nicht tue, dass es jetzt nur nach unten gehen kann, selbst wenn du das annimmst, dass ich keine Einflussmöglichkeiten habe und ich kann jetzt nur zugucken, wie es alles vor die Hunde geht, ist das immer noch interessanter, als wenn es irgendwie vor sich hin stagniert und eh niemand irgendwelche Einflussmöglichkeiten hat. Also ich finde das besser, wenn nur die Gegenseite Einflussmöglichkeiten hat, als wenn niemand Einflussmöglichkeiten hat. Weil dann kann ich mich auch gleich erhängen, kann ich irgendwie sagen, ich weiß, wo es hingeht. Das muss ich da nicht mehr erleben. Aber so gibt es wenigstens noch so ein Element, der ist noch nicht völlig klar, was jetzt passiert.
Also ich sage mir so, es ist so dermaßen völlig nicht klar, was jetzt passiert. Das ist dieses, es wird nicht langweilig werden. Davon können wir halt ausgehen. Eigens ist halt der, also ich teile halt auch nicht die Ansicht meiner amerikanischen Freunde, die halt sagen, so jetzt ist halt der Weg in die Autokratie da halt vorgezeichnet und da wird halt auch kein Weg dran vorbeiführen. Wir haben schon alle möglichen anderen merkwürdigen Umschwünge, insbesondere in der amerikanischen Geschichte gesehen, mit denen man vorher nicht rechnen konnte. Insofern schauen wir mal, es kann halt passieren. Wachsamkeit schadet halt nicht. Also ist halt die Frage, ob man sich halt darauf vorbereiten soll, dass passiert. Da ist die Antwort natürlich klar ja, weil es halt jetzt, da muss man halt jetzt mit rechnen und der Neprotismus, mit dem Trump da gerade in den Tach liegt. Also dieses we built the greatest swamp of it all. It will be a tremendous swamp.
The biggest swamp you've ever seen.
Und also wenn man sich anguckt, wen der halt jetzt da in seiner Regierung beruft, dann wusstet Leute halt irgendwie ins Finanzministerium, also Goldman 6 genau sagt, ins Finanzministerium.
Und ein General zum Verteidigungsminister.
Genau, also da gibt es halt eine Menge.
Da sieht man nicht viel von der, also der Slogan ist ja, wir wollen den Sumpf trockenlegen.
Genau, drain the swamp.
Bisher sehen wir eher mehr Sumpf als vorher. Aber ich mach mir, wie gesagt, hab ich ja auch vor der Wahl schon gesagt, ich mach mir gar nicht so um den Trump sorgen, sondern der Trump, also der Präsident, hat nicht so viel Einfluss. Der hat zwar viel Einfluss, aber er hat nicht so viel Einfluss wie Kongress, der Unter- und Oberhaus, und die sind beide in den Händen der Republikaner jetzt. Und der Supreme Court, der so die letzte Checks- und Balances-Sache ist, die die am Durchregieren hindern könnte, da gibt es seit, ich glaub, März letzten Jahres war das, gibt es da einen freien Posten, da ist einer von den Neuen gestorben, und die Republikaner haben einfach verhindert, dass ein neuer Kandidat von Obama benannt wird, das ist auch völlig unprecedented, das hat es noch nie gegeben, dass einfach gesagt haben, okay, wir stellen niemanden auf. Und Obama hat da zwar Leute vorgeschlagen, aber bis der Senat dem zustimmt, sind die halt nicht auf dem Posten. Und der Senat hat gesagt, okay, wir pokern jetzt, dass der nächste Präsidentenrepublikaner wird, was jetzt auch passiert ist. Und das heißt, dass die, wir können jetzt halt einen Ultra-Hardliner nennen. Und es gibt noch zwei oder ich glaube sogar drei andere Richter im Supreme Court, die über 80 sind, die also demnächst wahrscheinlich das zeitliche Segen werden. Trump kann jetzt auf Jahrzehnte hin den Supreme Court krass mit furchtbaren Hardlinern besetzen. Also da mache ich mir noch mehr Sorgen, denn der Supreme Court hat viele gute Sachen über die Jahre entschieden. Zum Beispiel, dass Abtreibungen erlaubt sind in den USA generell. Das ist eine Sache, die auf den Supreme Court zurückgeht und nicht auf den Kongress. Und da würde ich mir mehr Sorgen machen, als über Trump. Aber das ist natürlich jetzt irgendwie Potato, ob das... Ich würde es nicht trennen. Aber ich will nur sagen, das darf man nicht an Trump festmachen, sondern die Republikaner haben jetzt die Mehrheit. Und Trump ist der Typ an der Spitze. Aber das ist nicht nur der eine Typ. Wenn man jetzt Trump, wenn der jetzt einen Autounfall hat, sag ich mal, dann übernimmt sein Vize. Und das ist ein ganz übler Tea-Party-Verrückter. Der heißt Mike Pence und der hetzt seit Jahren gegen Schwule, gegen Homoehe, gegen Abtreibung, ist so ein Pro-Life-Typ und wollte irgendwie Planned Parenthood die Kohle wegnehmen. Das ist so eine Vereinigung, wo man sich als Familienberatung, und die helfen auch, einen Abtreibungsarzt zu finden, wenn es denn sein muss und so. Das heißt, das wird noch viel schlimmer. Trump ist zwar schlimm, aber der ist wenigstens kein Überzeugungstäter, sondern bei dem ist es doch so ein, es wirkt eher wie so ein Würfel, ja. Also seine Entscheidungen bisher wirken so ein bisschen so, als wenn es halt irgendwie Tageslaune ist, wie er entscheidet. Das heißt, da kann versehentlich auch mal eine in die richtige Richtung gehen, aber bei dem Pence, da kann gar nichts in die richtige Richtung gehen. Also es ist das Umfeld, was scheiße ist und Trump ist nur ein Aspekt davon.
Aber ich würde das halt nicht trennen wollen, weil der Punkt ist halt, dass diese republikanische Machtübernahme, die da passiert und wo Trump nun mal derjenige war, der halt dafür gesorgt hat, dass es passieren konnte, ist ja natürlich Teil eines großen Kontexts. Also wir haben ja rings um die Welt so eine Übernahme von Leuten, die, also nehmen wir in den Philippinen da der Tertel, der halt nun auch ein relativ extremes Beispiel ist. Wir sehen es halt in Osteuropa, irgendwie in Ungarn, in Polen, wo eher rechtskonservative autokratische Regierungen an die Macht kommen. Wir haben in Frankreich jetzt gerade irgendwie die Wahl zwischen irgendwie Marie Le Pen, die nun halt so quasi die dortige AfD ist und dem Kandidaten der französischen Konservativen, der den Seehofer gibt, wenn man sich seine positionen anregt. Also dagegen ist Seehofer, wenn man sich so seine positionen anguckt, fast ein Sozialdemokrat. Also das ist halt so und das heißt also die die Wahl in Frankreich ist eigentlich nur zwischen offen rechtsextrem und naja nicht ganz so offen rechtsextrem. Also das ist halt und dazu muss man sagen und der wird dann halt jeweils nicht ganz so schlimm ist.
Wird der hier noch gefeiert als der Kandidat?
Die Alternative wird gefeiert, aber wenn man sich dessen position anguckt, dann kann man einfach nur sagen, Entschuldigung. Und die Frage, die sich natürlich irgendwie, wo in Deutschland natürlich irgendwie das große Zitzen jetzt natürlich losgeht, ist halt die Bundestagswahl. Also die wird halt ja nächstes Jahr stattfinden und wahrscheinlich irgendwann im Oktober und die die Frage, was bis dahin noch alles passiert und welche Strömungen und Stimmungen halt dann irgendwie die AfD wie stark machen, ist halt auch nicht wirklich zu beantworten. Also wenn wir uns die Umfragen angucken und die letzten Wahlen, dann haben wir halt hier so ein, ich würde sagen so, naja, irgendwas zwischen 17 und 25 Prozent, wo halt irgendwie die AfD landen wird so. Und wenn man sich anguckt, wie die SPD gerade vor sich hin schwächelt, dann ist es halt durchaus möglich, dass also sowas wie Rot-Rot-Grün und jetzt hier in Berlin haben, wird möglicherweise einfach nicht funktionieren, weil die SPD so schwach geworden ist. Das heißt also, die Alternative ist dann halt hier zwischen sowas wie Schwarz-Grün, großer koalition und viel mehr Alternative gibt es dann halt eigentlich nicht mehr. Das sind dann halt so die...
Irgendeine geduldete Minderheitsgeschichte könnte noch gehen.
Nee, wenn es eine Mehrheit oder die AfD gibt, dann wird es die Mehrheit geben. Also da kannst du vorausgehen.
Also jedenfalls, ich finde auch, man muss ein bisschen von so geografisch begrenzten Betrachtungen wegkommen. Ja, das haben wir nicht gehört. Was wir hier gerade haben, ist weltweit ein Auflehnen der Bevölkerung gegen eine Politik, die ihnen im Grunde systematisch über die Jahre die Mitmachmöglichkeiten verwehrt hat.
Das ist nicht der Punkt, glaube ich.
Also das ist mein Eindruck, dass die Leute einfach den Eindruck haben, ich habe hier die Wahl zwischen A und B und die machen eh dasselbe. Das ist ja immer noch so.
Genau. Die Frage ist, was ist dasselbe? Und dasselbe ist halt genau, diese so zu tun, als wäre Globalisierung gut für die meisten Leute. Und das ist halt ein Ding, was die...
Naja.
Was halt einfach nicht... Lass mich kurz ausreden.
Ich argumentiere sogar...
Also der Punkt ist, wenn du dir anguckst, wer sind die Leute, die für den Brexit gestimmt haben, wer sind die Leute, die für die AfD stimmen, wie entwickeln sich die Stimmen in Frankreich, wer sind die Leute, die den Umgang irgendwie urban in die Macht gebracht haben, sind Leute, die sagen, okay, Globalisierung war vielleicht bisher ganz gut für uns, aber jetzt geht es an unser Eingemachtes. Also jetzt sind wir dran. Das ist halt der Unterrand der Mittelschicht und die werden halt von der Automatisierung und der Globalisierung gefressen. Und zwar absehbar. Wenn du dir in Amiland anguckst, wo die Jobs geblieben sind, also die halt irgendwie Output versus Jobs, siehst du halt ganz klar die Automatisierungseffekte.
MacJobs gibt es noch, so alles Dienstleistungs-Bullshit.
Ja, irgendwelche Dienstleistungs-Billig-Jobs und die werden interessanterweise auch noch durchaus die Nächsten sein, die halt irgendwie von der Automatisierung gefressen werden.
Ja, ich habe jetzt gerade erst so ein Ding gelesen über McDonalds, die in Amerika jetzt so Terminals aufbauen. Also da wird das Personal weggemacht. Da hast du dann am Tisch, also das habe ich hier noch nicht gehört, aber du hast an jedem Tisch irgendwie einen Terminal, du setzt dich dann irgendwie hin. Bevor du hingehst, mit deiner App bestellst du sozusagen, was du haben willst und das einzige Personal, was es noch gibt, ist jemand, der dir das dann aus der Küche zu deinem Tisch trägt. Das kannst du auch gut automatisieren, das haben die Japaner mit ihren Sushi-Dingern demonstriert. Also das geht alles den Bach runter und ich glaube, das ist schon längst jetzt sozusagen, als wenn jetzt irgendwie, es geht ans Eingemachte, das geht seit vielen Jahren ans Eingemachte. Wir haben schon ganz viele Jobs verloren.
Wir haben einen Tipping-Point überschritten und der Tipping-Code besteht darin, dass die Leute, die bisher arbeitslos wurden, hatten das Gefühl, sie kriegen noch irgendwie einen Job. Also einen, der so irgendwie noch irgendwas mit ihrem Williams-Level, mit ihrem Anspruch ans Leben, mit dem, was sie vorher verdient haben, zu tun hat. Und diese, die Sehne teilt jetzt links und rechts wegbröseln. In der Regel sind sie noch nicht davon akut betroffen. Also das ist ja auch sehr interessant. Also selbst bei den Wahlen im Amiland ist es ja so, dass die Leute, die akut betroffen waren, haben in der Regel Hillary gewählt. Aber die Leute, die Angst davor haben, dass sie betroffen werden, die haben Trump gewählt.
Moment, das ist aber auch nicht so einfach. Also ich habe ja ein paar Freunde in Amerika und ich habe beobachten können, dass die Eltern noch nicht betroffen sind, aber ihre Kinder sind betroffen. Die Kinder kommen mit einer erdrückenden Schuld aus dem College. Wir reden hier von sechsstelligen Beträgen. Und die finden dann, wenn sie Glück haben, einen Job im Supermarkt, der die Wagen zurückrollt, die Einkaufswagen vom Parkplatz. Die merken sehr wohl, wo es hingeht. Sie sind vielleicht persönlich gerade nicht betroffen und können noch den Rest der Familie durchfüttern. Aber dass sie nicht betroffen sind, stimmt nicht. Ihre Familie ist betroffen. Das darf man sich so einfach nicht vorstellen. Ich bin jetzt kein Globalisierungsfreund, aber Globalisierung hilft unter dem Strich den Leuten, indem es uns vergleichsweise viel wegnimmt und es unter vergleichsweise vielen Chinesen verteilt. Und denen geht es wirklich dramatisch besser. Aber das hilft bei uns natürlich nicht. Also es ist nicht so, dass Globalisierung inherent scheiße ist. Das ist sogar eine sehr humanistische Idee eigentlich. Man könnte sagen, wenn du sagst... Da könnte man drüber debattieren. Nein, aber ich will mal nur so zum Erkenntnis gewinnen. Will ich ja versuchen, den Punkt zu machen, dass du Globalisierungskritik als Krise des Humanismus werten kannst. Weil du sagen kannst, ich bin zwar eigentlich dafür, dass alle Leute irgendwie gleich gut leben sollen, aber wenn es über die Globalisierung herbeigeführt wird und ich plötzlich sehe, okay, dann geht es mir aber jedem massiv schlechter, dann wird irgendwann so ein Punkt erreicht, dass es wie mit den Flüchtlingen... Die meisten Deutschen sagen bei Umfragen, eigentlich finden sie es gut, dass den Flüchtlingen geholfen wird, aber wenn es Flüchtlingsheimen dann bei ihnen vor der Tür aufgebaut wird, dann sind doch wieder alle möglichen Leute dagegen.
Der Schwachpunkt einer globalisierungsargumentation ist, dass wenn es dann so wäre, dass tatsächlich irgendwie es nur eine Gleichverteilung gäbe, dann hätte ja niemand wirklich ein Argument. Aber was ja dabei passiert ist, dass es halt zu einer enormen kapitalkonzentration von sehr wenigen kommt, die an den richtigen Stellen sind.
Ja, ja, das stimmt natürlich.
Und das ist halt der Punkt, wie viel davon kommt dann halt an. Also ich erinnere nur mal an den unsterblichen Anfang von Snowcrash. Kannst du den hören an?
Ich hab den nie gelesen, muss ich dir sagen. Immer noch nicht.
Du wirst eine Kultur-Banause. Das solltest du aber dringend tun. Jedenfalls. Der Anfang geht halt ungefähr so, aus dem Kopf zitiert, nachdem die unsichtbare Hand der Globalisierung, das, was da war, so um die Welt verschmiert hatte, dass es aus der Perspektive eines pakistanischen Ziegelbrenners wie Wohlstand aussah. So fängt der Roman an. Stimmt ja auch.
Also das Versprechen der Globalisierung, dass es für uns Vorteile bringt, der ist natürlich Unsinn. Das bringt für irgendwie drei, vier Banker und all die Familie Vorteile. Für den normalen Bürger nicht. Aber das ist auch eine der Lügen, die die Politik den Leuten verkauft hat. Und ich glaube, das ist auch eine der Wurzeln dafür, dass die Leute jetzt halt mit ihrer Stimme irgendwelche Populisten wählen oder irgendwelche Extremisten. Ich finde Populist, finde ich, ein scheiß Wort.
Populist ist nicht gut.
Denn das ist die Jobbeschreibung des Politikers.
Ich finde doch Extremist nicht gut, weil Extremist, also ich habe nichts gegen tatsächlich Leute, die halt irgendwie extreme positionen betreiben. Weil das schafft ihnen den Gedanken so. Also mein Problem ist halt diese fremden Feindlichkeit. Also diese Xenophobie ist halt der Kern dieses Problems, dass halt einfach Leute nicht damit leben können, dass andere Leute anders sind. Und zwar auf allen Seiten. Das ist mir irgendwie...
Das glaube ich übrigens nicht. Ich glaube, wenn es dir nicht scheiße geht, dann hast du auch keine Probleme.
Ist deine Toleranz viel größer?
Ja, aber das ist doch der Punkt, dass den Leuten versprochen wurde, ihnen würde es besser gehen. Und wenn es ihnen dann nicht besser geht, dann muss es irgendwo hin. Und das kanalisiert sich gegen die Ausländer, weil das ist der einfachste Gegner. Dem geht es noch schlechter, die können sich nicht wehren.
Nicht mal nur die Ausländer, alle die anders.
Alle die anders sind, genau.
Genau, das ist halt der Punkt. Deswegen geht ja auch wieder, wenn du in Polen anguckst, halt irgendwie, wo es dann plötzlich wieder gegen die Schulen geht, so. Und wo du denkst, dachtest du...
In der UK, ganz groß nach Brexit, ja.
Genau, wir dachten so vor drei Jahren, okay, können wir dieses Thema endlich abschließen, so, dass irgendwie Leute nicht mehr wegen ihrer Sexualität diskriminiert werden, sondern dann geht es jetzt wieder los, so, weil das halt irgendwie unter der Oberfläche wieder weiterblowert.
Das ist zum Kotzen. Aber also was ich ja glaube, ist, dass der eigentliche, eigentlich Schuldige ist dieses Wachstumsversprechen. Die Globalisierungsleute haben uns ja versprochen, irgendwie dank ewigen Wachstums. Und die haben ja sozusagen argumentiert, die die Automatisierung hilft uns noch dabei, weil sie die Produktivität steigern wird. Und damit wird es allen gut geben. Allen wird es besser gehen. Und das ist halt Bullshit. Und die Leute haben es aber geglaubt. Obwohl es abzusehen war.
Naja und... Und sie haben...
Und diesen Wachstum, den gibt es halt nicht mehr. Und das kracht jetzt halt an den Stellen, wo die Leute sich nicht auf das, was sie haben, zum Zocken beschränkt haben, sondern wo die Leute mit Sachen gezockt haben, die sie für die Zukunft erwarten. Und das ist ja ein echtes Problem.
Ich glaube, es geht sogar noch weiter, weil die... Also, da gibt es so eine Rede von Orban, ich glaube, ich habe das schon mal drauf hingewiesen worden, ich glaube, 2008. So was sagte wie so, naja, ihr mit eurem Wirtschaftsliberalismus und dem daran hängenden gesellschaftlichen Liberalismus, ihr habt diese Krise verursacht. Und genau diese Verknüpfung von Demokratie, Menschenrechten, Gleichbehandlung von Menschen mit den negativen Aspekten von Globalisierung und Wirtschaftsliberalismus. Und der ist ja von der wirtschaftlichen Seite immer so gefahren worden. Er sagt, okay, irgendwie Marktöffnung bringt Demokratie, war ja lange das Mantra. Also darauf ist ja quasi auch die ganze EU-Erweiterung beruht ja genau darauf, auf diesem Gedanken zu sagen, wenn wir die Leute, also auch irgendwelche Länder, die in Osteuropa jetzt irgendwie nun nicht gerade so irgendwie so die strahlende Historie von irgendwie positive Demokratie hatten, wenn wir die in den Markt lassen, dann demokratisieren die sich quasi von ganz alleine.
Aber das Faszinierende ist ja, das stimmt. Also ich bin ja auch immer so ein bisschen negativ.
Das wollte ich ja gerade mal beschreiben.
Moment, aber es gibt diese Statistiken, von dem Hans Gosling heißt der, also jetzt nicht auf die EU beschränken, aber in China, Bangladesch, Indien sind die sämtliche Werte, die man für die Bewertung der Gesundheit einer Gesellschaft nimmt, haben sich massiv nach oben entwickelt. Die Lebenserwartung ist hochgegangen. Der plötzliche Kindstod ist zurückgegangen.
Ich meine Wohlstandspflicht gegen Sterben, das ist schon richtig.
Nein, aber das heißt, das ist das Versprechen gewesen, das mit der Demokratie ist so ein sekundär Ding, dass man sich denkt, wenn es den Leuten besser geht, dann haben die auch keinen Grund mehr, nicht Demokratie zu machen. So war jedenfalls, so habe ich das immer aufgenommen. Und also der erste Teil stimmt. Es geht wirklich fast allen Ländern auf der Welt sehr viel besser als noch vor 20, 30 Jahren.
Aber die Gegenthese, die Gegenthese dazu ist ja nur, weil wir halt quasi Free Energy haben. Ja. Also weil wir halt einfach dadurch, dass wir halt einfach den Planeten an niemand fahren, mit fossilen Energieträgern in der Lage waren, halt bis dato halt irgendwie Wachstum zu finanzieren, also beziehungsweise überhaupt zu ermöglichen.
Gut, aber, ja, warte mal, ich will einen Punkt machen.
Genau. Also der eine Punkt, der mir noch wichtig ist, ist halt genau diese Verknüpfung von Demokratie und Globalisierung und Wohlstand. Was wir überall ja gerade sehen, ist halt genau das Gegenteil. Wir sehen halt das, was die Russen gemanagte Demokratien nennen, das, was die Chinesen harmonische Gesellschaft nennen. Und wenn du dir Polen und Ungarn anguckst, dann haben die genau diese Ideen sich da weggeborgt und gesagt so, der gesunde Volkskörper braucht diese liberalen, schwulen Medien nicht. So Sachen kommen da von in Polen. So dieses, das ist doch sowieso die verdorbene, verkommenen Elite.
Meinst du, dass das wirklich zusammenhängt oder ist das die Gegenbewegung?
Die Gegenbewegung dagegen, dass sich die wirtschaftlichen Bedingungen durch die Globalisierung und den Neoliberalismus für die Leute in einer bedrohlichen Art und Weise entwickelt haben. Ich sage es noch nicht, dass es ihnen wirklich scheiße geht. Sondern es ist eine bedrohliche Entwicklung, wo sie absehbar sehen, wenn jetzt noch der Dienstleistungsmarkt weg automatisiert wird oder liberalisiert wird. Das ist ja dieses, das muss man vielleicht sogar mal erwähnen, dieses Teaser Agreement, dieses Trade and Services Agreement, ist wahrscheinlich für die Leute, die heute AfD wählen, noch eine sehr viel größere Bedrohung, persönliche Bedrohung als TTIP. TTIP ist nur irgendwie im Wesentlichen, naja gut, da können Investoren halt gegen Staaten klagen.
Teaser hat auch große Nachteile dabei, ist nicht der Todesstoß, der Teaser ist.
Genau. Teaser ist halt ein Ding, was halt völlig übersehen wird, heißt bedeutet halt die Globalisierung des Dienstleistungsmarktes. Das heißt also alles, was Dienstleistung ist, bis hin zu Altenpflege und all diese ganzen Dinge, die sie uns immer verkauft haben als, ja die Automatisierung wird halt die Manufacturing Drops platt machen, aber dann haben wir ganz viele tolle Dienstleistungsdrops. Die werden dadurch globalisiert. Das heißt halt, dass alles, was irgendwie an Dienstleistungen zum Beispiel von der öffentlichen Hand ausgeschrieben wird, bis auf ganz wenige Ausnahmen im Bereich Sicherheit, müsste dann innerhalb des gesamten Teasergruppen geöffnet werden. Heißt aber eben auch, dass zum Beispiel so was wie eine Straßenreinigung für hier geöffnet werden muss. Und jetzt überlegen wir mal ganz kurz, was es bedeutet. Da geht es ja nicht um Menschen, die diese Dienstleistungen ausführen. Da könnte man ja denken, ob hier zu einer spanischen Firma oder zu einer portugiesischen Firma. Nein, das ist ja egal. Natürlich werden die Leute von vor Ort anstellen vorwiegend, weil die Reise so, außer vielleicht in Grenzbereichen. Aber wer sagt dann, dass die Leute noch so lange tatsächlich arbeiten? Wer sagt dann, dass Straßenreinigung nicht demnächst von Robotern erledigt wird? Und dann gehören die Roboter nicht zu einer Firma, die zumindest hier noch ehestens mal Steuern zahlt und vielleicht zum Grundeinkommen beiträgt, sondern dann gehören die Roboter irgendeiner Firma, in Malta oder so, wo auch immer gerade die Steuergünste sind, oder auf Zypern, die halt hier diese Dienstleistung anbietet und sich hier noch drei Servicetechniker mietet und ein paar tausend Straßenreinigungsroboter auf die Straße schickt. Oder Burgerflip-Roboter oder was auch immer. Das heißt, dieses Teaser Agreement ist tatsächlich die präemptive Verhinderung von etwas, dass wir uns überlegen können, wenn wir Automatisierung haben und den Mehrwert, den die Maschinen bringen, vergesellschaften, dann könnten wir vielleicht damit leben. Aber wenn Teaser durchkommt, dann können wir das komplett vergessen. Dann ist vollkommen klar, dass die Gewinne, die daraus gezogen werden, insbesondere aus Dienstleistungsrobotik, werden nicht im Land bleiben, sondern die gehen dahin, wo es möglichst billig ist. Und das ist halt so ein Ding, was in der Politik gerade noch niemand so wirklich auf dem Zeige hat, weil die halt alle irgendwie immer nur so auf die nächsten zwei, drei Jahre denken.
Also ich bin mir halt nicht sicher. Sagen wir mal so, also eine These will ich immer ausrollen. Ich sage mal, wir haben jetzt irgendein Land. Der Wohlstand geht nach oben, aus welchem Grund auch immer. Und was ich glaube, was das Problem ist, ist, dass der dann innerhalb dieses Landes eben nicht gleich verteilt wird, sondern dass die Demokratie keine wirksamen Gegenmittel hat gegen korruption und die Bereicherung und die Zentralisierung von Macht und Geld innerhalb einer Demokratie. Die Demokratie verhindert nicht, dass es sowas gibt wie die Familie Springer und die Familie Mohn und der Funke. Quant, die zusammen einfach mal den Medienmarkt beherrscht. Also wir haben im Grunde drei oder vier große Firmen, die hier die Medien komplett einfach besitzen. Und das verhindert Demokratie eben nicht. Und das heißt, wenn der Wohlstand nach oben geht, dann werden die Leute, die das als Erste merken, als Einzige sind die in der position, um sich dann eben persönlich zu bereichern. Und es gibt eben keine funktionierenden Gegenmittel, mit denen die Demokratie sich gegen sowas schützt.
Also das Problem sehe ich bei den Medien nur so Mittel.
Das war jetzt nur ein Beispiel.
Das ist noch ein wichtiger Punkt, da sollten wir vielleicht noch drauf eingehen, weil natürlich das gehört doch sowieso alles denselben und ist halt irgendwie der dieselbe Mischpoke. Das ist aus meiner Erfahrung halt eigentlich eher irrelevant. Also es gibt halt natürlich so ein paar Ausnahmen, wie sagen wir mal bei Springer, die halt bestimmte Hausregeln haben, die aus meiner Sicht aber eher positiv sind. Also halt irgendwie keine Hetze gegen Juden, irgendwie Existenzrecht des Staates Israel verteidigen. Ist bei denen halt eine Hausregel so und aus der Historie von deutschen Boulevard-Medien heraus kann man sagen, okay, es ist wichtig, dass es so ist. Kann man darüber streiten, ob es jetzt in jedem Fall immer gut ist, aber zumindest gibt es da halt so einen gewissen Comment.
Und ist nicht völlig autoritativ von irgendeinem Diktator verhängt worden.
Genau, das ist halt so.
Ich meinte jetzt aber auch nicht, also okay, das habe ich scheiße formuliert.
Also die Medien sind glaube ich weniger das Problem.
Die Macht ist wichtig, aber mir ging es eigentlich um das Geld.
Das Geld konzentriert sich halt bei dir.
Das Geld ist für die Leute auf der Straße wichtiger, als ob sie das Gefühl haben, viel Einfluss zu haben. Dass er die erste Bedrohung für ihr Leben ist, ob sie sich Essen leisten können. Und wir sind jetzt so weit, dass die Ungerechtigkeit der Verteilung stark genug ist, dass in westlichen Demokratien die Hälfte der Bevölkerung entweder beim oder nur knapp über dem Existenzminimum vor sich hin vegetieren. Und das hätte so nicht kommen dürfen. Die Globalisierung hat funktioniert, aber sie hat eben nicht so funktioniert, wie es den Leuten versprochen wurde. Und die Frage ist, ob man das überhaupt noch gerade biegen kann. Weil rein juristisch gesehen kannst du den Leuten ja nicht irgendwie ihren ihren Reichtum wegnehmen, den sie sich da irgendwie erschlichen haben. Und die Frage ist, ist es die Aufgabe der Demokratie, das zu machen? Das ist ja auch eine Frage, die man mal stellen kann. Wessene Aufgabe wäre es gewesen, das zu verhindern?
Na ja.
Wie machen wir jetzt den Vorwurf?
Für mich ist das Problem dabei, dass der Eindruck entsteht, gerade insbesondere in Amiland, aber auch in austro-europäischen Gegenden, dass dieser Übergang zu autoritären Regimen, dass der durchaus von einem Teil dieser reichen Leute gewollt ist und dass das für die durchaus der nächste Schritt ist, der jetzt passieren muss, um halt irgendwie eine stabile Gesellschaft im Sinne von weiter Geld verdienen zu erzeugen, bis uns halt der Planet um die Ohren fliegt. Und die, also diese geistige Trennung von Demokratie und liberaler Marktwirtschaft, die jetzt gerade passiert, die ist in den Köpfen von diesen, nicht allen, aber vielen von diesen Leuten schon lange passiert. Wie sagen wir, China hat bewiesen, gelenkte Gesellschaft, Wachstum, Kapitalismus schließt sich nicht aus. Und diese, dieses Stabilität ist der, das ist das, wonach die Leute suchen, was die Leute haben wollen, was irgendwie das politische Angebot sein muss, die Rückkehr zu einer Welt, in der es weniger Veränderungen im Alltag gibt, und zwar gefühlte Veränderungen im Alltag. Da hättest du sagen, das, was die Leute wollen, die wollen, dass sich nicht so viel verändert.
Na Moment, das ist doch aber eine reaktion darauf, dass sie am unteren Minimum sind und dass sie verhindern wollen, dass es noch schlechter wird. Wenn es allen gut ginge, hätten die Leute auch überhaupt kein Problem mit Instabilität. Ja, wenn sie genug Puffer hätten, um eventuell kurzfristigen Niveau zu bekommen.
Den haben sie aber schon lange nicht mehr. Die nehmen alle auf ihre Kreditkarte.
Ja, aber nee, was ich, was ich argumentieren will, ist die Stabilität ist nicht das Nummer-1-Kriterium, sondern es ist nur jetzt das Nummer-1-Kriterium, wo die Leute alle davon ausgehen müssen, wenn es nur ein bisschen schlechter wird, muss ich hungern. Aber das heißt, eigentlich hätten die Leute kein Problem mit Instabilität, wenn es ihnen besser ginge. Das ist also nicht das Hauptkriterium, sondern es ist jetzt mehr so eine...
Ich glaube, es ist ein Kontinuum, weil ich denke, dass es schon so ist, dass Leute eine höhere Toleranz, das ist glaube ich auch belegt unter den Studien, eine höhere Toleranz für Veränderungen haben, wenn sie mehr Puffer haben, um halt das abzufielen. Aber der Puffer ist halt irgendwie von der Wirtschaft auch noch weggefroßen worden. Also das war ja noch mehr rausmelken, die Leute noch weiter den Kredit treiben, irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass irgendwie die Konsumgüter irgendwie angehäuft werden, obwohl sie sie eigentlich gar nicht brauchen. Und Leute halt in so einer Zinsfalle halten, ist ja tatsächlich ein wirtschaftliches Ziel gewesen. Da haben ja durchaus nicht wenige Leute gemacht. Und diese Trennung der Gesellschaft in solche, die halt einfach irgendwie rechtzeitig genug Geld anhäufen konnten und jetzt irgendwie davon so halt noch genug Puffer haben und dementsprechend für Globalisierung, Veränderung, mehr Liberalisierung und so weiter und so fort sind. Und denen, bei denen das halt nicht so ist. Und die halt wissen, jede Veränderung wird halt am Ende für sie scheiße sein. So. Das ist halt die Spaltung. Das heißt also, die Einkommensdifferenziale spalten halt eben auch zwischen können mit Veränderung und neuen Dingen klarkommen und denen, die halt nicht. Und die Angst davor, dass Veränderung nur noch zu ihren Unnüssen passiert, ist ja Erfahrungs. Also es hat ja einen Erfahrungshintergrund. Die können auf seit, sagen wir mal, ungefähr 2000 empirisch bestätigen. Können wir sagen, wir haben 15 Jahre, wo wir empirisch bestätigen können, dass Veränderung primär schlecht war. Zumindest gefühlt.
Was dieser These so ein bisschen entgegenspricht, ist jetzt, dass wir also eigentlich nach der These ausgehend hätten wir jetzt mehr Stabilität brauchen müssen. Das heißt, wir hätten so ein System haben müssen, wie in Russland, wo der Kreml für irgendwie Politik der ruhigen Hand und wir machen schon, dass alles gut wird. Stattdessen haben wir jetzt aber Brexit und Trump gekriegt, dass genau nicht die stabilen Auswahlen waren. Obwohl die in der Minderheit sind.
Und das ist aber das, was sie versprochen haben.
Trump hat Stabilität versprochen?
Wir brauchen eine Mauer. Wir haben jetzt wieder amerikanische Manufacturing-Jobs. So, die ganzen Leute, die für Kriminalität und Instabilität sagen, schmeißen wir raus. Brexit. Diese ganzen Polen und so, die da unsere Klempner-Jobs weggenommen haben.
Du, die Polen haben inzwischen gar keinen so schlechten Ruf in UK mehr. Die Bilder aus Calais, die haben Einfluss gehabt bei Brexit. Dieser, wie hieß der, der Jungle. Das hat die Leute wirklich, weil da hast du dann gesehen, irgendwelche mittellosen, die barbaren vor den Toren. Genau, und am besten noch, weißt du, Schwarze, die sehen dann nochmal ganz anders aus als das selbst Bild der Briten. Da wurden die Ängste geschürt. Das waren nicht so die Polen.
Wie auch immer, jedenfalls klar war halt, wenn du dir die Rhetorik anguckst von den Rechten, dann zielt die ja darauf ab, zu sagen, okay, wir haben hier unser Familienbild, so Kleinfamilie im Vorort, zwei Autos, ein eigenes Haus. Beide haben irgendwie einen stabilen Job, so oder die Mama ist Hausfrau. Sozusagen dieses 50er-, 60er-Jahre-Stabilitätsfamilienbild, diese Apple Pie Nummer in Amiland.
Ich sehe da trotzdem Widerspruch.
Warte mal, noch mal kurz zu Ende bringen. Und dieses Ideal ist ja quasi so ein Archetyp. Jeder kann sich seine version davon irgendwie vorstellen. Und am Ende läuft sie darauf hinaus, du hast genug Stabilität, um deine Kinder groß zu kriegen und irgendwie in Ruhe halt zu werden. Das sind halt so die beiden Dinge, die die Leute halt wollen. Und daraus folgt, wenn du die versprechen kannst, irgendwie so halbwegs glaubhaft versprechen kannst, dann wirst du die politische Auseinandersetzung gerade gewinnen. Und der Liberalismus kann das nicht versprechen. Alles, was er versprochen hat, war mehr Veränderung. So wir werden zu den Sternen fliegen, so nichts bleibt mehr, wie es war. Hyperhyper, mehr Veränderung. So und obendrauf natürlich noch so. Und wenn du dagegen bist, wenn du irgendwie eine andere Ansicht hast, wenn du ein anderes Lebensideal hast, bist du unmodern, bist du irgendwie Nazi, bist du homophob, so was sie wahrscheinlich sogar sind.
Rassist, ja klar.
Und dann dachten die Leute, naja, weißt du, wenn irgendwie homophober rassistischer Nazi sein halt irgendwie heißt, dass ich irgendwie meine Ruhe habe, dann bin ich halt homophober rassistischer Nazi.
Ja, also das glaube ich nicht. Was ich aber, also warte mal, ich habe glaube ich meinen Widerspruch nicht gut formuliert. Also ich meinte, meine Ausgangsbasis war, dass die Leute deswegen für Stabilität sind, weil ihr wahrgenommener Abstand zwischen ihrer Lebensrealität und dem absoluten Minimum, was sie zum Überleben brauchen, so gering geworden ist, dass sie überhaupt keine Schwankungen mehr haben wollen. Das heißt, es ging mir nicht um versprochene Stabilität in der Zukunft, sondern um, ab jetzt wird es garantiert nicht schlechter, weil wir gar nichts mehr machen. Das war so mein Eindruck. Auch von der CDU übrigens, die verspricht ja nicht, wir werden dieses tun, wir werden Steuern senken, sondern das versprechen sie, aber es ist allen klar, es wird nicht passieren. Das ist alles, die CDU wählt man, weil man glaubt, es wird zumindest nicht doll schlimmer. So, das ist die Stabilität, die ich meine. Und Trump ist jetzt aber die Art von, okay, wir müssen es jetzt einmal aufmischen. Wir werden jetzt hier anfassen, wir werden da anfassen. Und die einzige Erklärung, die ich finde, ist entweder Trump, die Leute sind so verzweifelt, dass sie sagen, ich bin jetzt unter die Linie gerutscht, von der ich glaube, dass das mein Minimum ist. Und jetzt ist auch egal, jetzt will ich hier den Hammer ins System.
Ich will das System brennen sehen.
Ich will das System brennen sehen. Das ist die eine These und die andere ist, dass Trump einfach Außenseiter genug ist, dass er der Einzige ist, dem man das noch glaubt, wenn er irgendwie sagt, ich hab zumindest den Plan, das besser zu machen.
Über 40 Prozent der Amerikaner haben nicht genügend Reserve, finanzielle Reserve, um mit irgendeinem Notfall, der sie mehr als 400 Dollar kostet, umzugehen. Und das zeigt, wie dünn die Decke geworden ist. Die Leute, die Trump gewählt haben, waren zum Teil die, und zum Teil die, die kurz darüber sind. Die vielleicht noch irgendwie 5.000 Dollar Kreditkartenreserve haben, die noch irgendwie gerade so klarkommen mit. Wenn irgendwas schief geht, dann kommen wir noch irgendwie so einigermaßen hin, aber die sich genau ausrechnen können, dass sie halt die Nächsten sind.
Naja, aber das ist ja ein Widerspruch. Du hast ja vorhin gemeint, sozusagen die Leute, die die armen haben, Hillary gewählt, die jetzt betroffen sind.
Ja, das ist die, die eins drüber.
Und die, also so, warte mal, du meinst es aber auch im Grunde schon.
Die, die gerade in den Abgrund runter gucken können. Kannst du dich noch erinnern irgendwie an deine Geschichte? Ich weiß nicht, wie der im Westen war. Im Osten gab es diese Geschichte so, wie sind die Nazis an die Macht gekommen, war, indem sie die verängstigten kleinen Bürger benutzt haben.
Ja.
Das war es so. Und wir dachten immer so, ja, verängstigte kleinen Bürger. Na ja, hm ja, so was sind denn jetzt verängstigte kleinen Bürger? Und wie kann man sich das nicht so richtig vorstellen? Das ist das, was wir jetzt gerade in der Farbe sehen. Das ist genau das, was wir gerade sehen. Das sind Leute, die Angst davor haben, dass sie die Nächsten sind, die halt von irgendwie Globalisierung und Wirtschafts-Globalisierung gefressen werden. Und nicht zu unrecht. Also ich meine, das sind halt irgendwie Leute, deren, also wenn du anguckst, Andrew Ng hat neulich gesagt, wurde gefragt, was sind dann die Tätigkeiten, die, also geistige Tätigkeiten, die weg automatisiert werden könnten? Er sagt, alles, wo ein Mensch eine Sekunde oder weniger braucht, um eine Entscheidung zu fällen. So, und wenn man sich kurz überlegt, dann ist das halt nicht alles, aber es ist halt eine erhebliche Menge. Die einzigen, die noch übrig bleiben, sind Ingenieure und Programmierer.
Nee, die Leute, die übrig bleiben, sind die, die den Prozess designen. Denn das ist so, so designen wir alle unsere Prozesse, dass an jedem einzelnen Schritt höchstens eine Sekunde nachgedacht werden muss. Und das machen irgendwie eine Handvoll Leute, die die Prozesse und der Rest ist dann...
Gut, es gibt sicherlich noch eine Menge andere kreative Tätigkeiten, die im Moment aber auch schon durch Scheiße bezahlt werden. Ja, also so. Und das ist halt so ein Ding, wenn wir uns angucken, wohin die Reise da geht, dann ist halt klar, dass der Umgang der Gesellschaft damit, das Automatisierung und Globalisierung, beides Hand in Hand sicherlich, den Leuten halt die Möglichkeit raubt, noch an die Zukunft zu glauben. Das ist, glaube ich, der Kernpunkt. Es gibt halt keine vision der Zukunft mehr. Die Linke hat es nicht geschafft, eine vision der Zukunft zu sein. Sie hat gesagt, die Rate der Veränderung in deinem persönlichen Alltag, was deinen finanziellen Status angeht, was deine allgemeine Lebenssicherheit angeht, wir können die runterbringen. Zum Positiven. Wir können dafür sorgen, dass es erstmal nicht schlechter wird für dich und dann wird es vielleicht sogar noch besser. Das wäre eine vision, die die Linke gerade bringen muss. Aber sie bringt sie nicht. Alles, was sie tut, ist mit den Händen wedeln und irgendwas von Menschenrechten erzählen, was am Ende interessiert, das die Leute nicht.
Du, ich muss dir mal eine Sache erzählen, die mir da auch fällt. Im Gespräch mit meinen Eltern und anderen Leuten aus der Altersgruppe, die haben miterlebt, wie von ihrem Studium aus, wo völlig klar war, es ist Wurst, was du studierst, du wirst einen Job finden, wie diese Sicherheit der Reihe nach weg erotiert ist. Und jetzt haben sie sozusagen Kinder und Enkel, die überhaupt nicht wissen, wo es hingeht. Und das ist verbunden mit einem tiefen Gefühl von Schuld, so ein bisschen. Aber auch von, okay, wir müssen jetzt hier mal was machen. Weil das ist das, was sie zurücklassen werden. Und die sind jetzt alt genug, dass sie drüber nachdenken, was eigentlich ihr Vermächtnis ist für die Welt. Und die sehen, okay, also das haben wir jetzt vor die Wand gefahren, da muss jetzt was passieren. Und meine These ist, dass die deswegen auch für so Leute wie Trump anfällig sind. Weil die sagen, okay, das ist jetzt so ein Gefühl der Dringlichkeit haben. Weil ich mache jetzt hier nur noch ein paar Jahre. Irgendwie, oder wer weiß, wie lange ich hier noch auf der Erde bin. Ich muss jetzt, jetzt muss ich hier was tun, sonst sind meine Enkel irgendwie, müssen die hungern. Also die haben sogar noch viel mehr ein Gefühl der Dringlichkeit als die Leute, die tatsächlich selbst betroffen sind. Weil wenn du selbst in der situation bist, dann kannst du dir ja mal irgendwas ausmalen. Aber die Leute haben sozusagen eine Rente, sie können genau ausrechnen. Die haben keine akuten Probleme bei sich selbst. Die können auf andere gucken und sagen, das fährt hier gerade vor die Wand. Und da ist sogar noch ein bisschen mehr revolutionäres Potenzial als bei den Kids, die von der Uni kommen. Weil die, das ist auch eine Sache, die mich zutiefst mitnimmt, ehrlich gesagt. Wenn ich sehe, wie die Leute von der Uni kommen und auch in der Uni schon sich gar nicht irgendwie politisch engagieren, weil sie denken, das landet alles auf Facebook, das wird dann im Bewerbungsgespräch gegen mich verwendet. Sondern nur auf so einer risikoarmen Ebene, wo irgendwie keiner dagegen sein kann, engagiert man sich noch politisch so für irgendwie Schwulenrechte und so. Sachen, wo keiner was gegen sagen wird.
Aber jetzt mittlerweile schon. Ja, aber du weißt, was ich sagen soll, ne? Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Das ist ja genau das, was ich so meine. Die suchen sich halt dann politische Zwecke, wo sie ein Gefühl von Selbstwirksamkeit haben.
Oder unpolitisch. Also wir haben mal vor einer Weile darüber geredet, dass Veganertum auch so ein bisschen so eine Sache ist. Das ist eine Sache, die ich jetzt konkret machen kann.
So Veganertum, Tierrechte.
Auswirkung, genau. Also es muss nicht mal was Politisches sein. Aber ich finde diese Vorstellung, dass man sich selbst so, also nicht zensiert, aber beschränkt, was ja noch schlimmer ist, in seinem Tun, weil man das Gefühl hat, das wird irgendwann gegen mich verwendet werden. Ich mache jetzt nur noch Sachen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es die Züge nehmen.
Meinst du, das gibt es nicht?
Also es ist vielleicht in Amiland jetzt gerade motivation, aber ich glaube, das meiste, was halt an so, ich würde das nicht Fake-Aktivismus sagen, weil das wäre ungerecht.
Es gibt so Extremaktivisten, gibt es natürlich noch. Natürlich, aber der breite Studenten-Korpus war früher viel politisierter als heute. Und ich führe das darauf zurück. Also es gibt immer noch Leute, die sozusagen Vollzeitaktivismus machen.
Ich glaube, das Problem ist, dass sie ein Gefühl von Unwerksamkeit haben. Also dass halt, wenn du halt irgendwie jetzt anfängst, deinen Lebensstil umzustellen, so sage ich.
War das früher nicht genauso? Die 68er, die haben da irgendwie rumdemonstriert und dann ist der, ist ihnen ihr Studentenführer erschossen worden.
Aber da gab es übrigens tatsächlich genau den selben Effekt, nämlich diesen sogenannten Rückzug ins Private. Den Effekt gab es damals genauso, dass die Leute dann halt angefangen haben, da so ein Mental-Health-Gramming zu machen und zu sagen, so irgendwie, wenn ich mich halt irgendwie verbessere und irgendwie...
Die Selbsthilfe-Bewegung?
Mein Leben, mein Körper.
Positives Denken?
Genau, gewaltfreie kommunikation. Das ist ja ein Re-Run, was wir da gerade haben. Diese ganze Safe-Space-Geschichte und so, das gab es ja alles schon mal in den 70ern. Das ist ja genau, das ist nun nochmal wieder aufgekocht und mit anderen Farben so. Und dieses Rückziehen, zurückziehen auf, wenn wir unsere interpersonelle kommunikation von Gewalt befreien, was dann halt zu dieser PC-Geschichte wurde und so. Also dieses ganze Ding ist ja nicht neu. Und was damals ja passiert ist, ist, dass dann die Leute, die halt noch was tun wollten, die sind ja dann in eine neoliberale Bewegung gegangen. Das sind ja die Leute, die dann tatsächlich angefangen haben, Firmen zu bauen, die halt irgendwie Silicon Valley hoch groß gebracht haben.
Oder in die RAF.
Das war halt die andere option, aber das waren halt ein paar weniger. Also das ist halt auch so eine generation von Leuten, die halt heute Firmen, teilweise nicht ganz kleine Firmen leiten. Die sind halt richtige Hippies gewesen. Und die haben halt immer gesagt, okay, das wird halt nix mehr hier. Meine Energie ist halt hier verschwendet. Ich gehe jetzt mal halt in die Wirtschaft. Da kann ich wenigstens mit meinem Unternehmen noch irgendwas bewegen. Das ist ja durchaus so eine ganze generation von Leuten, die da so sind jetzt, die halt dann irgendwann, als sie irgendwie so in den 70ern halt irgendwie gemerkt haben, so okay, das wird hier alles nix mehr. Dann haben die halt Anwalt studiert und haben halt irgendwie Unternehmen gegründet oder angefangen, so Zeug zu machen. Und die Frage, wie sich das jetzt auswirken wird, was jetzt passieren wird, wenn die Leute, gut, da gibt es auch lauter vegane Unternehmen und so, da gibt es ganze Bewegungen, veganes Unternehmertum, die sich jetzt neulich darüber aufgeregt haben, dass die britische Pfundnote, die neue, nicht vegan ist.
Ja, weil da irgendwie Teig, was war das?
Genau, die Bündnis-Unternehmung, die Spuren.
Also nicht tatsächlich als Element von dem, sondern bei der Herstellung.
Also es gibt einen Teig in der Tinte oder irgendwie so was. Also naja, gut, da kann man sich da natürlich lange drüber aufregen, aber das ist halt natürlich so ein relativ esoterisches, religiöses Problem. Und diese Art von Konflikten werden natürlich auch in den Medien gerne hochgekocht. Die sind natürlich, weil die sind emotional belastet, das ist quasi Konflikt-von-Glaubenssystem, hat halt irgendwie diesen Planeten-Retten-geht-uns-alle-an-Anspruch. Und aber dieses Fake-Planeten-Retten-über-so-was führt halt zu einem, also an irgendeinem Punkt glaube ich auch zu so einer frustration. Und ich meine, dass das halt irgendwie mit der industriellen fleischproduktion so nicht weitergehen kann, schon wegen der methanproduktion, ist ja eigentlich allen klar. Aber dann halt daraus eine Ideologie zu machen, hilft halt eben auch nicht.
Na gut, aber lass uns mal ein bisschen zur Politik zurückkommen. Also ich fand ja die Fragestellung hochinteressant, ob wir jetzt so eine Art Chaos-Welle haben, um das mal so ein bisschen pseudomythisch, irgendwie metaphysisch zu beschreiben, die jetzt über unser Universum rollt und die in ihrer Bugwelle so Sachen wie Trump und Brexit macht. Und was passiert, wenn die über unser Land hinweg rollt?
Ja, der Bundestag soll man da gerade, ja.
Ja, und ich denke mal, das ist eine durchaus hochinteressante Sache, das zu beobachten. Selbst wenn man sich selbst einen Einfluss oder einen Abspräch da irgendwas unternehmen zu können, ist es allein schon das zu beobachten absolut spannend. Und ich gucke ja gerade so ein bisschen nach Österreich, weil da erscheinen sich ja gerade dieses Brexit- und Trump-Ding zu wiederholen, dass die Leute alle so, nee, der kann es aber nicht werden. Das war bei Brexit völlig klar. Das kann auf keinen Fall die Leute können nicht.
Das ist dieser Hof, oder wie heißt der?
Genau, irgendwie von der FPÖ. Ich glaube, Hofer hieß der. Aber jedenfalls, es gibt einen Kandidaten, wo sozusagen der Mainstream der Meinung ist, naja, klar wird das der, weil der andere ist undiskutabel. Und dann wird es halt am Ende doch der andere. Und das steht sozusagen in Österreich aus meiner Sicht knapp bevor. Das ist jetzt der Rerun von einer Wahl. Die selbe Wahl lief schon mal. Und beide Kandidaten haben sich da im Grunde völlig disqualifiziert in einem unmoderierten TV-Duell.
Stimmt.
Und das war ein total Desaster, wo also die Medien völlig so, was zur Hölle ist denn hier gerade passiert? Ja. Und dann gab es halt diese Wahl. Und da hat der Mainstream-Kandidat, der von den Grünen ist der wohl, wenn ich mich da jetzt recht in Sinne, der hat halt gewonnen. Und dann hat die FPÖ erfolgreich die Wahl angezweifelt, weil es irgendwelche formalen Probleme gab. Und jetzt gibt es halt nochmal eine Wahl. Und das wirkt alles sehr Trump-mäßig auf mich, bis auf die Neuwahl. Und zwar in beide Richtungen. Weil es gibt ja auch bei Trump gerade den Versuch, hier nochmal irgendwelche US-Bundesstaaten nochmal auszuzählen. Und zwar geht das aus, ich weiß gar nicht aus welchen Gründen. Lassen Sie das die Stein machen. Das ist die Kandidatin der Grünen in Amerika. Die hat irgendwie ein Prozent der Stimmen oder so gekriegt. Also egal, was die da jetzt neu auszählen, das wird nicht zugunsten der Grünen sein. Aber die hat gerade so ein Re-Run, eine Neuzählung in drei von den besonders umkämpften Bundesstaaten angeordnet. Und also ich kenne mich da mit dem Wahlrecht nicht genug aus, ob es da jetzt eine Neuwahl geben kann. Ich glaube nicht, aber ich sehe da so gewisse Parallelen.
Na ja, also was da passiert, ist ja ein bisschen komplex. Also in diesen Staaten gibt es ja durchaus Grund, mal nachzuzählen. Und der Grund besteht darin, dass es halt eine Auffälligkeit gibt, dass in Staaten, also in Counties, wo bestimmte Wahlkompeten eingesetzt werden, lag Trump ungewöhnlich weit vorne. So, da gibt es das Gegenargument, dass es natürlich auch Counties sind, die halt irgendwie eine entsprechende Demografie aufweisen, die Trump halt begünstigt, aber das ist halt irgendwie sozusagen eher ein schwacher Gegenargument. So, und was die Stein da glaube ich gerade tut, ist noch mal versuchen, das Argument, dass allein dadurch, dass sie angetreten ist, sie möglicherweise Hillary die Wahl gekostet hat, was sich für diese Staaten durchaus...
Also, könnte sein, ja....
kann man machen, ja. Also, ist jetzt nicht klar, dass irgendwie alle Wähler, die halt die da Grüne gewählt hätten, halt im Zweifel Hillary gewählt hätten. Wahrscheinlich wäre das nicht der Fall gewesen, aber der Margin, mit dem Hillary verloren hat in diesen Staaten, nach der jetzigen Auszählung, ist kleiner, als die Anzahl der Stimmen, die das Stein da bekommen hat.
Also, wir reden hier von in drei Bundesländern zusammen irgendwie 80.000 Stimmen.
Nee, 100, 150.000. Also, bei jedem Fall...
Also, es gibt noch... das ist ein größerer Rahmen, aber so die drei unteren mit den kleinsten, da sind die Abstände so was wie 10.000, 20.000 und 40.000. Und plus irgendwie noch ein paar Zerquetscher. Und zusammen kommen die irgendwie auf 80.000. Also, das ist jetzt nicht viel. Das muss man schon sagen.
Genau.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es eben auch Wahlkreise in den USA, wo nur so 100 Leute wohnen. Und das ist ja in der Beziehung halt schon viel. Und es gab eben von beiden Seiten während der Wahl schon Vorwürfe der wahlmanipulation, die ich auch durchaus glaube, dass die gerechtfertigt sind. Auch sogar von beiden Seiten übrigens.
Insofern, also ich finde es ja ganz gut, dass sie da anfangen nachzuzählen, weil zum einen wird es dieses Wahlcomputerproblem möglicherweise endgültig beenden, weil in einigen von diesen Counties gibt es, glaube ich, sogenannte DRI-Systeme.
Also das heißt, die haben noch nicht mal ein Paper-Trailer.
Genau, also die halt einfach nur in den Speicher schreiben, wo also die neue Auszeichnung besteht, noch auf den Knopf zu drücken, den Bong noch mal neu ausdruckt. Und die halt noch mal zu auditen, also halt irgendwie dann mal in die Kisten reinzugucken und zu schauen, ob da wirklich die Firmware drin ist, die drin sein sollte und so weiter. Und ob die Touchscreen-Alignments hinhauen und so.
Erzähl doch auch noch mal von vor der Wahl. Es gab da nämlich noch so ein paar Geschichten von den Wahlcomputer-Forschern in den USA. Die einfach auch nichts publizieren wollten, weil sie Angst hatten, dann irgendwie als Trump-Anhänger gesehen zu werden und so.
Das war halt tatsächlich ganz schön übel, weil die Kritik an den Wahlcomputern in den USA ist ja schon lange sehr umfangreich und die sind ja auch wissenschaftlich ganz gut belegt. Es gibt immer wieder eine Menge Vorfälle, wo Wahlcomputer kaputt sind, wo die Touchscreens so kalibriert sind, dass eine Stimme von einem Kanal zum anderen wandert. Verkackte Software-Updates, jede Menge von so Problemen, wo man irgendwie hier schon lange sagen würde, ne, also lassen wir mal, wo sind unsere Bezettel, wo sind unsere Bleistifte? Und diese Probleme hörten in dem Augenblick auf, in der von der akademischen Community berichtet zu werden, wo Trump dieses, die Wahl ist gegen mich gerickt. Also wir, so, in dem Augenblick, wo Trump es so hier sagt, oh ne, dem helfe ich aber nicht mit meiner Forschung. Demso, die Wahl ist halt, ja, wird da halt betrogen werden und sie wird gegen mich betrogen werden. In dem Augenblick, wo Trump mit dieser Story um die Ecke kam, hatten diese ganzen Forscher, die ja halt auch alle eher etwas liberaler und ein bisschen linker und irgendwie jetzt irgendwie keine Lust hatten, sich da irgendwie mit diesen Breitbart-Nazis irgendwie gemein zu machen, die hatten dann halt so ein bisschen harte Hemmungen halt zu publizieren und zu sagen so, ok, hier sind diese Probleme, die eine Probleme und solche Probleme. Und daraus resultierte dann natürlich aber auch so ein gewisses Vakuum, ok, wir wissen darüber, was da halt eigentlich alles an Problemen gerade existiert. Und das hat sich jetzt halt ein bisschen geändert, nachdem Alex Halderman auf diese statistischen Anomalien in diesen Swing States gewiesen hat. Das war halt der Anfang von dieser Auszählungsgeschichte. Alex ist halt so mit der renommierteste Forscher, aber was war Computerangehend in den USA? Der hat auch schon die Wahlsysteme in den Estland kaputt gemacht. Also die digitale Wahlsysteme. Also der hat eine lange Liste von Scharten von tollen Wahlsystemen. Und hier auf seinem Keyboard so. Ja, der kann sich da aber wieder eine Kerbe ins Keyboard schnitzen. Also wenn der sagt, wir müssen da mal einen Audit machen, dann gehst du halt hin, machst einen Audit. Das ist halt nicht optional. Und der hat halt gesagt, okay, da gibt es diese statistischen Anomalien, lass uns noch mal eine Auszählung machen. Und das dauerte halt relativ lange interessanterweise. Der ganze Nate Silver, so einer von diesen Statistikhelden, der da halt auch relativ viel Raumfragen machte, meinte, nee, das kann ja eigentlich nicht sein. Und der meinte dann aber auch, nachdem Trump dann sagte, ja, nee, also neu auszählen geht ja überhaupt nicht und das ist ja undemokratisch und seit da schlechte Verlierer und irgendwie, wenn, dann müssen wir auch mal über Kalifornien reden und so, also halt da so völlige Nebelkerzen warf, meinte dann Nate Silver, okay, na gut, wenn der so antwortet, dann müssen wir nochmal neu auszählen.
Also ich hab inzwischen halt mir einer erklärt, was da genau, was Trump für ein Problem mit der Neuauszählung hat. Und zwar ist es so, wenn jetzt Neuauszählung im Raum stehen, dann dauern die ja ein bisschen. Und es ist eben abzusehen, dass dann zum Zeitpunkt der Wahl durch das, also die eigentliche Wahl des Präsidenten findet durch das Electoral College statt, wo die Wahlmänner abstimmen. Und wenn jetzt durch die Auszählung sich bis zu dem Termin hinaus zögert, dass man wirklich definitiv sagen kann, welche Wahlmänner in den einzelnen Bezirken sind, dann könnte das die gesamte Wahl sozusagen niederknüppeln. Und das will Trump halt gerne verhindern. Er möchte gerne eine definitive Aussage haben, wenn er irgendwie im Januar ernannt werden soll. Dann soll das aber auch völlig außer Frage sein. Und er glaubt halt, dass jetzt so Hinhaltetaktiken kommen. Also es ist nicht völlig irrational, dass Trump plötzlich von die Wahl ist gegen mich geregt. Aber jetzt wollen wir nicht nochmal nachgucken. Das hat nicht nur damit zu tun, dass er irgendwie glaubt, er hat manipuliert, sondern das ist auch irgendwie... Der ist ja, der hat sich das ja angeguckt vorher. Und die Republikaner machen ja seit vielen Jahren nur Hinhaltetaktik gegen Obama. Nur so eine irgendwie Salamitaktik.
Ja, und jetzt können sie mal ihr eigenes Doppel bekommen, ja.
Ja, aber der hat es beobachtet und er hat gesehen, wie das läuft und merkt jetzt, okay, jetzt machen wir das gegen mich.
Wie effektiv das sein kann.
Jaja, das ist wirklich scheiße effektiv. Und da hat er gerade Muffensausen. Ich glaube nicht, dass er glaubt, dass da rauskommen kann, dass er nicht gewonnen hat oder so. Sondern der möchte halt nicht als lame duck direkt irgendwie anfangen als Präsident. Nur auch nicht vom Aussehen. Ist er ja sowieso nicht, weil die Ehe wie alle Häuser in der Hand seiner Partei ist. Aber er möchte nicht irgendwie so als der Bittsteller ins Amt kommen.
Also die Wahlcomputerforscher sind da natürlich in einer schwierigen position. Es gibt ja noch so andere Geschichten aus anderen Ländern. Ich lass mal den Landesnamen weg, wo die denn mit der Regierung geredet haben und die Regierung dann so sagte, naja, so ist ja gut und schön, dass sie jetzt irgendwie Schwächen in unserem Wahlcomputersystem gefunden haben. Aber wir betrachten eine Wahl als erfolgreich, wenn dabei weniger als 100 Leute umkommen. Und wenn sie jetzt halt anfangen, irgendwie hier unser Wahlsystem in Frage zu stellen, dann können wir mit Sicherheit davon ausgehen, dass mehr als 100 Leute umkommen. Überlegen sich das mal gut. Und dieses Problem stellt sich natürlich in Amiland auch. Da gab es ja genug irgendwie Right-wing Militias, die halt sagten so, naja, also hier, wenn es nicht unser Trump ist, dann ist aber hier irgendwie immer ordentlich Party. Und da muss man sagen, dass irgendwie Alex Holderman, muss man schon sagen, halt echt Mut so, also in so einer situation zu sagen, so okay, übrigens, so die Integrität des Wahlsystems gebietet, dass wir jetzt in diesen Fällen, wo es halt echt knapp ist und die möglicherweise Wahlanscheiden sind, halt einfach nochmal nachsehen.
Na ja, da ist ja auch völlig undiskutabel, da jetzt irgendwie was gegenzuhaben. Was ich noch sehr spannend fand, ist, dass es eigentlich jahrelang von den Behörden immer nur Mauern gab, wenn es um die Sicherheit der Wahlcomputer ging. Aber als dann diese Russen, die Russen hacken uns die Wahlrhetorik an Fahrt gewann in den USA, da gab es dann auch in letzter Minute plötzlich tatsächlich auch von staatlicher Stelle irgendwie Anläufe, um nochmal eben schnell die Wahlcomputer zu auditieren. Hattest du da nicht noch irgendwelche Geschichten erzählt, dass die dann plötzlich auch noch anfingen irgendwie so, die CIA hat ihr Red Team losgeschickt und so Geschichten hieß es gar so?
Nein, nicht die CIA, aber die haben in großem Umfang halt angefangen, die digitalen Wahlsysteme, insbesondere halt die Tabellierungssysteme halt zu auditieren, weil sie halt Muffensausen hatten, dass die Russen ihnen herumzahle waren. Und da gibt es halt immer noch, also gerade gab es eine Geschichte, dass die führenden Obleute im Senat-Intelligence-Komitee haben einen Schreiben geschrieben an den direktkommissionen und an den Chef vom Senat, wo sie gesagt haben, so ja hier wir wissen übrigens, dass irgendwie unsere Geheimdienste auf Evidenz sitzen zur russischen Beeinflussung der Wahl. Und wir können jetzt in diesem offenen Schreiben natürlich nicht sagen, welche Evidenz wir meinen, das werden wir auf den Secret Channels kommunizieren, aber wir finden, das müsse halt mal de-classified werden, weil halt irgendwelche wesentliche informationen so oder... Und da bist du natürlich dann als irgendwie direkt in der national Intelligence halt irgendwie in der etwas... Naja, nicht so ganz einfachen situation, ne?
Der DNI ist übrigens im Moment James Clapper und der hat gerade seinen Rücktritt angekündigt.
Ja, aber er ist zum ersten Mal hier genommen.
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich, also...
Ich denke der würde... Also an seiner Stelle würde ich jetzt auch mal spontan...
Oh, ich bin schon so alt über die Rette.
Schon so spät? Ja, ich muss noch meinen Resturlaub nehmen. Genau. Also die situation, halt irgendwie dann zu sagen, okay, jetzt releasen wir mal irgendwie die Evidenz darüber, ob die Russen jetzt darum gecybert haben oder nicht, die ist natürlich heikel, ne? Also weil, also die Demokraten haben ja bisher immer halt diese position vertreten zu sein. Ja, gut, wir fangen jetzt mal da nicht halt an, rum zu stressen, weil Unity of the Country und so, also wir wollten auch irgendwie alle versuchen, dass das irgendwie da alles wieder schön wird. Und jetzt sind sie offensichtlich an dem Punkt, wo sie sagen, naja, ja, nee. So, und dann gut, da haben sie halt jetzt die Grünen vorgeschickt, damit es irgendwie nicht gar so krass aussieht, aber offensichtlich ist...
Um diesen Partisanen-Moment daraus zu holen, ne?
Genau. So, bzw. die andere Story, die ich höre, ist halt, dass die Demokraten auf gar keinen Fall wollten und echt pisst waren, dass Justin das gemacht hat, weil sie natürlich damit halt irgendwie die Interessen von einem großen Teil der demokratischen Basis vertrat, die sagten, na klar, wenn wir da irgendwie nochmal was nachbohren können, dann bohren wir natürlich nach, während irgendwie die Demokraten establishment so, nee nee, Unity of the Country können wir doch nicht machen so. Also die denselben Nummer, weswegen Al Gore verloren haben.
Na ja, wahrscheinlich wollen sie auch nicht, dass rauskommt, wo sie die Wahlen beschissen haben, weil das würde mich echt wundern, wenn das nur die Republikaner machen.
Das ist natürlich eine andere option, ne?
Das ist ein Zupf, ein großer Zupf. Der größte Zupf, den wir je gehabt haben. Ja, na gut, aber wir sehen jedenfalls diese Chaoswelle aus Amerika auch zurück nach Europa gehen. Die nächsten Länder, die so ein bisschen akute die Stabilisierung haben, sind Frankreich. Die Präsidentschaftswahl haben wir schon angesprochen. Dann jetzt das Post-Brexit-Chaos in den UK, ist also noch deutlich übler, als wir das vorher angenommen haben. Da werden jetzt die Gerichte angerufen, um rauszufinden, wer überhaupt beim Parlament, also erstens, ob das Parlament angehört werden muss dazu oder ob das reicht, diese Befragung, ob die Regierung jetzt einfach Brexit machen darf. Da hat jemand geklagt und der High Court hat entschieden, das Parlament muss auch noch mal zustimmen. Und dann kam die Frage, okay, ist das jetzt aber nur das Parlament in London? Oder auch das schottische Parlament wollte auch noch mal extra und dann wäre auch Wales und Nordirland wäre auch noch mal.
Und dann kommt der ganze Kammer in Wales?
Und da wird jetzt, also das ist ja mein Perspektiv, das würde ich mich fände ich ja so geil, wenn irgendwie Kanada noch gefragt wird oder so.
Und das Traal in Neuseeland.
Und Indien vielleicht auch noch. Also das ist ein Fass ohne Boden, was sich da gerade auftut. Und es ist durchaus auch so ein bisschen unterhaltsam, wenn man sich da so ein bisschen aus der Schusslinie bringt und sich selbst gegenüber leugnen kann, dass es einen betrifft.
Die Briten haben ja da auch irgendwie noch so institutionen, wo du denkst so, hä?
Alleine dieser Supreme Court, der ist nämlich relativ neu. Der ist überhaupt erst, ich glaube, 2008 war die Meldung, wo der gegründet wurde. Und vorher gab es ein Mechanismus namens Royal, wie hieß das? Prerogative. Eine ganz großartige Geschichte. Es ging damals um eine Insel, die den Briten gehörte und die die Amerikaner gerne als Flugzeugbasis haben wollten. Und die Briten haben halt gesagt, ja klar, wenn ihr das braucht, könnt ihr das haben, wir haben hier Special-Friendschaft und so weiter. Und haben die Ureinwohner von der Insel einfach entfernt.
Die Ruggers hier.
Und die klagen seit Ewigkeiten, möchten gern zurück auf die Insel und möchten gern Entschädigung kriegen. Und sie haben natürlich auf jeder nur denkbaren Ebene völlig recht mit ihren Entschädigungen. Aber die Briten versuchen das halt auf irgendwelchen formalen Wegen immer wieder irgendwie jahrelang hinzuhalten und so weiter. Und irgendwann hat der High Court eben entschieden. Und dann gibt es aber nur noch eine höhere Instanz über dem High Court, nämlich das House of Lords, also das Oberhaus, was eigentlich nur noch so, hm, früher haben die mal Einfluss gehabt.
Die Old Farts mit den Perücken.
Genau. Also diese Leute, die durften dann irgendwie in besonderen Krisenzeiten durften die solche Entscheidungen treffen und es hieß dann Royal Prerogative. Und das sah irgendwie gar nicht gut aus und haben sie gesagt, na gut, dann machen wir hier noch einen Supreme Court und der entscheidet das jetzt. Also das ist alles ein Riesensumpf, aus dem keine Gewinner hervorgehen können.
Also die nur so als Exercise für den Hörer. Wenn ihr nochmal euch über interessante britische Ämter informieren wollt, dann gibt es den Queens Remembrancer, der ist neulich auch zu gewissem Ruhm gelangt, weil er in dem neuen William Gibson Roman Peripheral nach der Apokalypse eine große Rolle spielte. Und ja, löst euch das mal die Wikipedia Artikel durch, die sind wirklich ganz hervorragend.
Es gibt lauter so richtig geile, es gibt zum Beispiel einen Typen, der im Parlament durch die Keller läuft und prüft, dass da keine Fässer mit Schießpulver liegen.
Ja, ist ja wichtig, ne?
Ja, aber so, und zwar läuft der da aus traditionsgründen mit einer Fackel rum. Also es ist halt tradition, ja so. Also naja. Aber wir sollten da nicht zu laut lachen, ich mein. Bei uns gab es ja auch diverse hohe Trassen.
Das stimmt. In Bayern zum Beispiel. Da gibt es ja so einige. Gut, apropos Bayern. Die Präsidentschaft war in der Armin-Land hatten wir schon.
Apropos Bayern, ich hab hier Fake News als nächstes. Was kommt denn jetzt?
Fake News? Echt, aber Fake News? Stimmt.
Ach, über die OPEC wollten wir auch noch reden und über die Mediterranean Welfare so viel.
Ja, wir lassen uns mal mit den Fake News weitermachen. Genau, Fake News. Fake News war ja so eine von diesen Debatten, die wir schon immer mal wieder so ein bisschen hochblubbern hatten. Und jetzt nach den Wahlen kamen die ja noch mal richtig mit Macht, so nach dem Motto Fake News haben Trump an die Macht gebracht. Und ich muss ja ehrlich sagen, ich finde diese Debatte völlig hanebüchen. Also weil, ich meine, Medienenden gab es schon immer.
Früher nannte man es einfach Bildzeitung.
Medienenden gab es schon immer und die waren teilweise auch durchaus einflussreich und es gibt jede Menge von irgendwelchen komischen Einflussgruppen, Lobbygruppen, Fak-Experten, die halt irgendwie ihre Fake News positionieren in den mainstream Medien. Und nur weil jetzt tatsächlich Fake News auch irgendwie mal auf Facebook landet und da halt eine gewisse Eigendynamik entwickelt und ein paar hunderttausend Leute da drauf klicken und möglicherweise glauben, weil sie es dem Ente nicht sehen, finde ich irgendwie jetzt, da finde ich dieses Hyperventilieren so ein bisschen unangemessen, ehrlich gesagt.
Nee, das sind die Verlage. Ich halte das für eine Strategie der Verlage, um gegenüber Facebook ihre Macht zu demonstrieren. Ja, weil Facebook arbeitet ja aktiv daran, die Verlage weg zu optimieren, als Mittelmann, den keiner braucht, damit die Nachrichten...
Ich glaube, Facebook sind die Verlage mittlerweile egal.
Ja, eben. Und das ist jetzt der Versuch...
Ich glaube, Facebook sind die Verlage eher als Content-Lieferanten, die dafür sorgen, dass es nicht ganz so wild nur ist. Und ich glaube, dass Facebook diese Fake-News-Nummer einfach passiert ist. Was wir da sehen, ist, dass der Algorithmus, mit dem die Bewertung passiert, wann Sachen in der Timeline angezeigt werden, welche Sachen nach oben gespült werden, deshalb du siehst ja nicht alles, was deine Freunde teilen auf Facebook, sondern du siehst, was Facebook denkt, das wichtig für dich ist. Und nicht nur die Sachen, die deine Freunde teilen, sondern auch was andere Leute teilen. Und dieser Algorithmus ist ihnen glitten. Das passiert. Alles, was da geschehen ist, ist nichts weiter als tatsächlich ein Programmierunfall, um es mal deutlich zu sagen.
Das halte ich auch nicht für richtig. Das kannst du doch gar nicht messen. Du siehst ja nur, was der für dich glaubt, nicht was der für alle anderen glaubt. Du kannst immer nur kleinere Messungen von ihm machen.
Aber Facebook sieht doch, was er für die anderen glaubt.
Aber der Nachweis ist für den Verlag oder für den Kritiker überhaupt nicht zu erbringen, dass dieser Algorithmus schiefgelaufen ist.
Nee, aber tatsächlich ist er gesellschaftlich schiefgelaufen.
Aus Facebooks Sicht war er doch schon immer der Algorithmus, der aus Facebooks Sicht funktioniert. Genau getan, was er tun sollte.
Also er hat aus Facebooks Sicht ganz hervorragend funktioniert, hat nämlich einfach die Werbeclicks nach oben getrieben. So Angry People Click. Und wir haben ja diese Geschichte gesehen mit irgendwie den Wasmoldawien oder so, wo die Leute halt irgendwie Fake News Farmen eingerichtet haben und dann sich davon neue Autos kaufen konnten und so. Aber der Kern dabei ist doch eigentlich, dass dieses nach oben spülen von hochemotionalen Nachrichten, Nachrichten, die ein hohes Reclick-Potenzial bzw. Reshare-Potenzial haben, ist ja kein Zufall. Der beruht halt einfach darauf, dass Facebook mehr Werbung verkaufen will. Und am Ende muss man einfach sagen, ist, wenn man die Theorie, dass Fake News jetzt irgendeine große Art von Einfluss auf die Wahlen hatte, müssen wir sagen, Trump ist wegen Online-Werbung an die Präsidentschaft gekommen. Es gibt noch einen zweiten Datentunkt dafür. Nämlich, dass wenn man guckt, wo Trump sein Geld hingetan hat, hat er 200 millionen Dollar ausgegeben für Facebook-Werbung, die targetet war gegen Hillary-Wähler. Der hat ganz gezielt richtig viel Geld da reingesteckt, auf Facebook Hillary-Wähler und Wählerinnen zu targeten, um die vom Wählen abzuhalten. Und der nicht mal den nicht mal pro Trump-Werbung reingespielt, sondern irgendwelche News-Bits, irgendwelche Memes, irgendwelche Videoschnipsel, die zeigen, dass Hillary scheiße ist und man sie eigentlich lieber nicht wählen sollte. Nicht mal besonders aggressiv, sondern eher so tatsächlich so votadis-desiration. Das heißt also dafür sorgen, dass halt die zwar denken so, ja nee, also Trump will ich nicht wählen, aber ich gehe halt auch nicht wählen, weil Hillary wählen ist halt doof. So. Und diese, also zweiter Datenpunkt. Online-Werbung destabilisiert den politischen Prozess. Also Online-Werbung führt dazu zur psychologischen Beeinflussbarkeit von Menschen, die eine Wahlentscheidung treffen.
Und ich finde, ich finde dieses Stabilitätsgefahr soll, finde ich, entsetzlich. Wahlen haben nicht das Ziel, Stabilität zu zu bringen oder zu haben. Die Wahl ist gerade der eine Punkt, wo du eben nicht die Stabilität einfach weiterführst, sondern ein Element, der das Chaos einführst.
Aber was da passiert, ist es ja eben nicht, dass die Leute eine nationale Entscheidung getroffen haben, was sie eigentlich tun sollten.
Aber das ist doch sowieso nicht so. Das war doch noch nie so. Dass die Leute rational entscheiden, sonst hätten wir nie, sonst würden die Leute die Linken wählen. Die sind die Einzigen, die die position der Mehrheit tatsächlich vertreten. Nee, was ich sehr bemerkenswert fand, ist, dass es so eine Pyramide gab aus Leuten, die über Fake News gemeckert haben. Wir haben ja ganz oben so Leute wie Spiegel und Fatz. Die haben früher gemeckert über so Leute wie BuzzFeed. So und diese Fake News-Geblubber, was im Moment durch die Medien blubbert, das kam von BuzzFeed. Wir haben also im Moment den Effekt, dass BuzzFeed sich über die anderen Fake News ärgert. Und zwar also BuzzFeed macht ansonsten so Click-Page-Scheiße.
Das ist dann ja Click-Page und nicht Fake News.
Das ist alles Click-Page. Ja, aber der Punkt ist doch, aus Sicht von so dem süddeutschen Verlag, ist das doch dasselbe, ja? Wir sind hier die Leute, wir sind doch hier die Leute, die seriösen Content bringen und die da hinten ist der Slum. Haltet euch von denen fern. Und BuzzFeed hat sich jetzt halt gewehrt, indem sie gezeigt haben, guck mal, also die wirklichen Fake News, das sind die da hinten und die kommen von diesem irgendwie Content-Tank, diese gelangweilte Teenager aus, von wo auch immer das war. Und da habe ich ja echt, bin ich vom Glauben abgefallen, als so Leute wie die Süddeutsche dann tatsächlich BuzzFeed zitiert haben als Quelle dafür, dass Fake News ein Problem ist. Das fand ich absolut großartig.
Also ganz ehrlich, diese Medien aufregend über Fake News ist sowas von unehrlich.
Das ist die Deutungshoheit, um die es da geht.
Das ist nicht nur die Deutungshoheit, das ist auch einfach der Versuch, den eigenen Umgang mit wirklich schattigen und unseriösen News-Quellen zu vertuschen. Also ich meine, diese Quelle Internet ist noch nicht so lange her.
Ist immer noch so, natürlich.
Ne, gibt es nicht mehr so lange.
Nein, pass mal auf. Was es heute gibt, das ist also...
Sind halt diese Twitter-Einblendungen.
Reddit hat vor einer Weile angefangen, wenn sie irgendeine Meldung bringen, irgendwie, ich glaube der Politics-Subreddit ist das. Und die Schlagzeile ändert sich, nachdem sie darauf verlinkt haben, dass sie das rechts anzeigen. Die Headline was altered after Link. Und das ist heute bei jeder zweiten Story. Das heißt, ich finde das genauso fake, als wenn du von vornherein scheiße schreibst, ist wenn du im Nachhinein nicht dazu stehst, was du eigentlich geschrieben hast. Sondern dann haben die so AB-Tests, nennen sich das. Du guckst halt, was die Leute mehr triggert und wo es mehr Werbeklicks gibt. Und mit dem fährst du dann weiter. Und alle Artikel werden heute nach dem Publizieren noch editiert. Und zwar nicht nur so Tippfehler raus, sondern die Überschrift wird sinnentstellend umgebaut. Sagt danach das Gegenteil dessen, was vorher gesagt hat. Und es gibt überhaupt keinen Hinweis mehr darauf, dass da mal was anderes stand. Das ist einfach heute bei diversen Medien Standard. Und das ist, das finde ich viel schlimmer als Fake News, die wenigstens so ehrlich sind irgendwie. Ja, haben wir halt gesagt.
Es gab gerade diese Geschichte mit irgendwie, wo die ganze amerikanische Mainstream-Media-Landschaft eine Meldung darüber, dass auf CNN Hardcore-Porno lief.
Und das ging auf einen Tweet zurück.
Es ging auf einen Tweet zurück, ja. Und die, wenn die, also wenn wir das mal kurz irgendwie vergegenwärtigen, das ist ungefähr so, als wenn sie aus dem, wie heißt dieses Magazin, was sie bei Men in Black immer hatten?
The Inquirer, national Inquirer, haben sie glaube ich gehabt.
national Inquirer, ja, genau. Also guck doch nochmal Men in Black, wir wollen nochmal verlinken Men in Black. Gibt es in Men in Black 1 diese tolle Szene, wo irgendwie der Rookie eingeführt wird in den Drop. Und der alte Mann, der halt irgendwie ihm zeigt, was geht. Sein Mentor. Er sammelt halt erstmal am Zeitungs-Qs diese ganzen Ultra-Tabloids ein, mit diesen Elvis ist wieder aufgetaucht und so. Also diese ganzen...
Die Sachen, die einer an der Kasse im Supermarkt irgendwie verschenkt werden sozusagen, weil die eh nix wert sind, ja. Auf dem Niveau. Und der meint so, was machst du denn da, was liest du denn da für einen Scheiß? Und dann meint er, das ist der letzte brauchbare Journalismus. Die haben auch rausgefunden, dass Elvis noch lebt, so nach dem Motto. Und das stimmt alles, ja, so. Und der Lacher hinter den Kulissen, was viele nicht wissen, ist, dass es tatsächlich stimmt, der national Enquirer ist nämlich in den 70er Jahren durch furchtbare Storys aufgefallen und hat sich ein paar fette Gerichtsverfahren eingefangen. Und seitdem sind die sozusagen dafür bekannt, wenn die schreiben, der und der irgendwie kogst auf der Party, dann hat er auch gekopft. Also das war wirklich, das war ein mehrschichtiger In-Joke, diese Referenz.
Also jedenfalls nur noch mal zu illustrieren. Solche Fake News oder Quellen hochgradig zweifelhafter Gehütte sind ja total üblich im Medienbetrieb gewesen. Und der einzige Unterschied ist, dass sie jetzt halt durch die Social-Media-Dynamik werden die halt schneller verbreitet und entfalten halt ihre Wirksamkeit. Und da haben halt keine, naja, da hat dann halt keine Redakteur drauf geguckt, der jetzt irgendwie, den man halt irgendwie rausschmeißen könnte. Aber wahrscheinlich würden die sowieso nicht rausgeschmissen. Und seit dem Punkt, wo mehr Klicks mehr Geld bedeutet, ist es egal. Ist es egal.
Und es bleibt nachvollziehbar, denn wenn jemand auf Facebook deinen Artikel zitiert und du änderst den danach, ändert sich das Zitat nicht. Das heißt, das ist auch ein echtes Problem für die Zeitung, weil das sie halt beim Bescheißen hindert. Aber also diese CNN-Sache war deswegen besonders spannend, weil die genau nach dieser Fake-News-Welle kam. Nachdem die etablierten Medien sich einmal so richtig darüber ausgekotzt haben, wie wenig die anderen recherchieren, und bei uns gibt es ja zumindest zwei unabhängige Quellen, danach hat es die halt einmal alle weggefegt, weil sie halt ohne eine zweite Quelle diesen CNN-Scheiß gemacht haben. Und der absolute Brüller war ja, dass Fox News dann bei CNN anrief und um ein Statement bat, und CNN hat die Fake-Meldung bestätigt. Irgendein Typ bei CNN hat es geglaubt, weil es auf Twitter stand. Also das ist der Einfluss von viralen Meldungen. Das darf man nicht unterschätzen. Nicht mal der, der hier beschimpft wird zu Unrecht, hat das nicht geglauben wollen, sondern mal kurz nachgefragt, stimmt das denn überhaupt? Ja, so, also es ist wirklich alles, diese Fake-News-Geschichte, wir sehen das jetzt zum ersten Mal, aber das gibt es natürlich schon immer.
Also, das sage ich wohl schon immer, das gibt es halt wirklich schon so quasi wirklich immer, die, wir haben so eine hübsche Geschichte gefunden, dass Abraham Lincoln, einer der Gründungsurväter der amerikanischen Geschichte da, dass der beinahe mal eine Wahl verloren hätte wegen Fake-News. Und die Geschichte, wir tun sie in die Links rein, ist insofern spannend, weil, also damals waren halt Demokraten und Republikaner noch umgekehrt, also die Demokraten waren die Sklavenhalter-Partei und die Republikaner waren halt eher so der industrialisierte Norden, der halt irgendwie den weg von der Sklavenhalterei wollte. Und die Demokraten haben damals eine Kampagne gestartet, die darauf hinauslief, mit irgendwie so so ein Fake-Pumflet, was irgendwie so ein Büchlein, was irgendwie gedruckt wurde und lauter News-Items in irgendwelchen Lokalzeitungen. Die sagte so, ja, Abraham Lincoln vertritt die Meinung, dass es irgendwie eine aus Schwarzen und Weißen gemischte, neue amerikanische Superrasse geben solle. So und diese, also das war damals halt so der, also damals war halt Rassentrennung halt so der wesentliche entscheidende Faktor, der die Leute auseinandergetrieben hat.
Und Eugenik war angesagt.
Genau.
Also was unser heutiges Hightech ist, war damals Eugenik. Genau, also wir müssen jetzt aus verschiedenen irgendwie Leuten eine Superrasse züchten.
Oder die Rassen getrennt halten.
Das war auch eine Begründung für die Rassentrennung natürlich. So nach dem Motto, die Minderwertigen dahinten, die wollen wir nicht, dass sie unseren Genpul verschmutzen. Also was aus Sicht eines irgendwie frisch von einer deutschen Schule kommenden Schülers ist, dass alles Nazi-Gedanken gut, aber das war auch gerade so, wir müssen hier durch gezieltes irgendwie Cross-Breathing, müssen wir hier die guten Gene zusammenführen und irgendwie behinderte Kinder abtreiben und so. Das sind ältere Gedankengänge als die Nazis und die sind also auch in Amerika sehr populär gewesen.
Ja, jedenfalls, lest mal diesen Artikel, der ist wirklich sehr unterhaltsam. Man sieht da die Mechanismen, die man heute sieht, auch wieder. Nämlich, dass News-Items einfach ausgedacht werden, Gerüchte gestreut werden, um einzelne Kandidaten und einzelne Themen halt irgendwie zu diskreditieren. Und das Problem dabei ist auch, dass in dem Augenblick, wo man weiß, dass so was passiert, gibt es wiederum für die Gegenseite, auch die ist doch sowieso alles nur Fake-Defense. Das ist das, was die AfD ja gerade macht. Also, wann immer über irgendwie ein ihrer funktionäre mal wieder irgendwie Sachen berichtet werden, wie groß das Vorstrafenregister ist, was halt irgendwie die für irgendwie bizare Business-Deals gemacht haben, wie oft die insolvent waren sollten, also die üblichen Dinge, die halt über so Kandidaten berichtet werden, ist halt alles Lügenpresse. Und wenn man es nicht mehr bestreiten kann, dann, dass es tatsächlich wahr ist, sagt man ja. Aber das ist ja unfair, dass ihr euch auf uns konzentriert. Also, dass also der, die jetzt sich dem Blick der Öffentlichkeit aussetzen müssen. Und dieser Mechanismus zu sagen, so ist alles sowieso Lügenpresse und Fake News richtet sich ja nur gegen uns, ist natürlich durchaus machtvoll. Also der hat natürlich auch ein gewisses Potential. Und der Antreiber, ich glaube, war dabei durchaus, dass das Fake News an sich als Mittel der Nazis, also über Verbrechen von Flüchtlingen zum Beispiel, die, da hat es ja auch mal diese Huxmap-Leute sich ja so ein bisschen angeguckt, dass halt also ein Großteil dieser Meldungen, nicht alle, aber ein Großteil der Meldungen über irgendwelche angeblichen Verbrechen von Flüchtlingen halt irgendwie erstunken und erlogen ist. Und es gibt halt welche, die stimmen und die sind wahr. Und die wurden aber so lange in der Mainstream-Presse nicht berichtet. Oder sagen wir mal jetzt nicht besonders intensiv berichtet, dass halt irgendwie genau dieses Gefühl entstanden ist, diese Meldungen werden unterdrückt. Und daraus entstand halt dieser Vakuumraum, diese Möglichkeit, da halt mit diesen Fake News reinzugehen. Also das ist halt schon durchaus auch so, dass überhaupt diese Viralität und diese Möglichkeit des Verbreitens nicht nur technisch da ist, sondern eben auch im Raum der möglichen erzählbaren Geschichten. In dem Augenblick, wo man halt irgendwie sagt, okay, der Staat, das System, will Dinge geheim halten oder will halt irgendwie Dinge nicht berichtet haben. Und dann stimmt es halt manchmal auch, dann stimmt es halt manchmal, dass aus irgendwelchen Rücksichtnahmen bestimmte Sachen nicht berichtet wurden. Entsteht halt genau dieser Glaube, okay, alles, was im Internet steht, muss halt wahr sein, weil das ist ja das einzig unabhängige Medium. Obwohl, neulich hatte ich einen Taxifahrer, das war echt interessant. Ich rede ja gerne über Taxifahrer. Das war echt interessant, weil der hat offensichtlich sich nur aus öffentlich-rechtlichen Quellen informiert. Also halt irgendwie Deutschlandfunk und deutschlandradio und so, und irgendwie LBB und so. Und war so richtig strammer AfDler. Ja, also richtig so.
Also da kann man nicht irgendwie Fake News und Facebook...
Nee, der hatte kein Internet. Hat keinen Internet.
Was gibt's da?
Der hat jetzt den ganzen Tag am Auto und im radio. Und war trotzdem strammer AfDler. Kann passieren. Also ist halt nicht so, dass das halt irgendwie nur eine Medienversagenung aufs Internet zu schieben ist.
Übrigens, auch der Trump-Slogan Make America Great Again ist alt. Den hat Reagan schon benutzt. Das weiß wahrscheinlich auch nicht jeder. Also viele von diesen Sachen sind alt. Wir haben jetzt nur die Intensität oder Zusammenstellung ist irgendwie neu. Oder wir haben sie vergessen. Auch die Idee überhaupt. Also das fing an. Na ja, es fing an. Ist wahrscheinlich auch falsch. Aber eine der bisherigen so Sachen, wo es häufiger Fake News, ähnliche Sachen gab, nennt sich AstroTurfing. AstroTurf ist eine Kunstrasenmarke in den USA. Und die Idee, also in den USA gibt es diesen Begriff Grassroots Movement, für wenn sich so tatsächlich organisch aus der Bevölkerung eine Art Protestbewegung bildet. Und wenn du so eine Protestbewegung fakest, indem du eben irgendwelche, was weiß ich, das entweder mit robots, mit Bots machst, ja, auf Social Media Bots, oder wenn du die Unterschriften fakest und du hast gar nicht so Leute, oder du bezahlst irgendwelche Schüler dafür, dass sie mit Protestplakaten rumlaufen, das nennt sich AstroTurfing. Und das ist ein ganz altes Ding, das wird seit vielen, vielen Jahren betrieben. Ganz alte Nummer. Und auch ansonsten gibt es einige Mechanismen um News von den Leuten, um eine, naja, deniability nennt man das. Also, dass man bestreiten kann, dass es von mir kommt, dass ich aber eigentlich trotzdem Geldgeber bin. Das sind alles Mechanismen, die schon länger aus Wahlkämpfen gibt. Auch diese überhaupt, dass es Thinktanks gibt, geht auch darauf zurück, dass man halt sagen kann, ja, das hat aber nicht der Trump gesagt, das hat der Thinktanks und so gesagt. Ja, und der wird natürlich von denselben Leuten finanziert, aus demselben Spektrum. Und also nichts von diesen Fake News ist neu. Das ist nur eine Sache, dass die Verlage jetzt so mit dem Rücken zur Wand stehen. Aus meiner Sicht, das ist jedenfalls meine Erklärung, dass sie versuchen, jetzt eben die Deutungsuheit zurückzugewinnen, indem sie den Rest als Fake News abkantzeln.
Wie gesagt, ich denke schon, dass man Facebook da von der Verantwortung nicht freisprechen kann, weil die, man muss sagen, sie haben halt einfach den politischen Prozess ruiniert für kurzfristigen Profit aus Online-Werbung. Und das finde ich moralisch schwierig.
Ja, aber sie haben nie den Anspruch erhoben, was anderes zu sein.
Nee, aber der Effekt, also der gesellschaftliche...
Ich sage nicht, dass die was Gutes tun. Ich sage nur, die haben noch nie...
Ist schon klar, aber der gesellschaftliche Effekt ist so, dass ich jetzt nicht mehr sehe, dass man das unbetrachtet lassen kann. Nee, das ist keine Frage.
Nur ich kann jetzt hier nicht irgendwie sagen, unmoral, unmoral, die sind angetreten mit der Behauptung, sie machen jetzt Werbung.
Schon klar, aber der...
Also wenn ich irgendwie ein Werbenetz anpisse, weil sie Werbung einstrahlen.
Ja, ich glaube aber, dass die sich nicht so ganz darüber im Klaren sind, oder vielleicht besser im Klaren sind, als wir glauben, aber halt irgendwie nicht entsprechend handeln, dass sie halt mit dem, was sie da tun, also auch insbesondere halt, was das Targeting angeht, die Möglichkeit, Wähler so präzise mit Werbung zu targeten, gab es halt vorher nicht. Und das ist halt eine Sache, die sollten die halt einfach lassen. Ich glaube, ich finde, das ist einfach eine Sache, die halt einfach eine, also wohl, ich sag mal, die paar Prozent Profit mehr, die sie da rausziehen können dafür, die sind nicht dadurch zu rechtfertigen, was halt irgendwie im Rest der Gesellschaft deswegen passiert.
Ja, aber wenn du auf Targeting verzichtest, kannst du auch zurückgehen zur Fernsehwerbung. Also das ist genau ihr Alleinstellungsmerkmal.
Die Frage ist halt, wo ist halt Schluss?
Ich widerspreche den nicht. Ich sage nur, aus deren Sicht wäre das sozusagen...
Also aus meiner Sicht könnte man Werbung komplett abschaffen. Ich habe keinen Bedarf an Werbung. Ich finde Werbung vollständig überflüssig. Irgendwie, dass irgendwie die besten Ingenieure auf diesem Planeten damit zu tun haben, irgendwie uns mehr Werbung reinzudrücken, um irgendwie, damit wir mehr Scheiß kaufen, den wir nicht brauchen, halt ohnehin für ein Verbrechen, was man irgendwie abschaffen muss. Insofern alles, was irgendwie diesen Sumpf trockenlegt, um mal Trump zu zitieren, finde ich ja ganz gut so. Aber momentan wären die sich ja noch gerade dagegen, dass irgendwie man überhaupt Adblocker benutzen darf und so. Na ja gut.
Ja, nun ja, also wir wollten hier noch ein besonders krasses Beispiel für Fake News ansprechen. Wollen wir das ansprechen?
Na klar.
Gut, du zuerst.
Welches hatten wir denn hier?
Pizzagate.
Pizzagate, ne, das musst du machen.
Nee, ich hab da keinen Bock drauf.
Ich weiß von Pizzagate nichts. Ich weiß nur, ich hab irgendwann diesen Hashtag gesehen, wo die Pizza geht und klickte da durch und war irgendwas was mit pädophilen Ring in einer Pizzeria und klick weg. So, dann war ich hier vorbei.
Also das ist eine Sache, die auf 4Chan gestartet ist. Mehr muss man eigentlich schon gar nicht sagen. Die haben in den Podesta-Mails auf Wikileaks irgendwelche Hinweise zu finden geglaubt dafür, dass es sich um einen pädophilen Ring unter Demokraten handelt, die sich in einer bestimmten Pizzeria treffen, weil, und die Beweislage ist so ein bisschen dürftig an der Stelle, weil der Typ ist halt komisch und ist auf Kinder ausgerichtet mit seiner Pizzeria und hängt so komische Kunstwerke an die Wand, die irgendwie sehr verstörend aussehen. Und das stimmt, aber das heißt noch nicht, dass es ein pädophilen Ring ist. Dann haben sie so ein Video gehabt, wo man irgendeine Band, die sie da mal eingeladen hatten angeblich, auf dem Video ist aber nicht zu erkennen, wo das tatsächlich stattgefunden hat. Ja, das könnte nicht irgendwo sein können. Und diese Band ist auch irgendwie, naja. Jedenfalls, also sie haben so eine Kette aus mehr oder weniger schwachen Indizien. Und ihre Behauptung ist eben, dass in diesen Podestamails so Tarnbegriffe benutzt werden. Und das FBI hat offenbar vor ein paar Jahren so ein Handbuch veröffentlicht, wo drin steht, wenn Pädophile sich unterhalten und die sagen Pizza, dann meinen sie minderjähriges Kind. Also auf dem Niveau eine Beweisführung, wo ich so denke, ne, also sorry, das ist mir jetzt auch mal eine Zeit zu schade. Aber damit sind die halt rumgelaufen und haben confirmation-bias gnadenlos ausgenutzt. Wenn du einmal nach irgendwas speziell im Suchst, dann siehst du halt überall Hinweise darauf. Und entsprechend sind dann irgendwelche Teenies mit ihren Smartphone-Kameras zu dieser Pizzeria gelaufen, haben sich irgendwie in den Keller gesetzt und haben sich dabei gefilmt, wie sie deine Pizza bestellen und so. Und die ganze Zeit so, gleich kommen sie, gleich kommen sie. Also es ist eine Hysterie, hat sich da irgendwie gebildet. Und also, ja, aber es hat es in die Presse geschafft, wenn auch nur als, ach, diese Pizza geht, Leute, das ist ja ein tolles Beispiel für Fake News. Also so richtig befördert hat es, glaube ich, kein einziges Medium zur großen Konsternierung von den Fortschränk-Leuten, die mich also jetzt geradezu belagert haben per Mail, weil ich im Blog halt geschrieben hab, Leute, also. Was?
Die liefen bei dir auf?
Die liefen dann bei mir auf, weil ich das nicht befördert habe. So und dann hab ich gesagt, Leute, also, kommt wieder, wenn ihr Beweise habt, ja. Und dann kommt auch nicht zu mir damit, sondern geht zur Polizei, weil das hier ein Internetpranger, irgendwelche Leute, natürlich, pädophilie, ja, da markt nicht mit, so selbst, wenn ein Pädophiler ist, ist es nicht mein Problem.
Gibt's halt hier nicht, nee.
Das machen wir nicht so, aber das haben mir einige Leute recht übel genommen. Aber also, das ist halt ein Beispiel dafür, was passiert, wenn man so aus Beweisketten versucht, irgendwelche Sachen zu schließen. Da muss man verdammt vorsichtig sein. Vielleicht sollten wir noch kurz erklären, confirmation Bias, wie das funktioniert. Also confirmation Bias heißt sozusagen, wenn ich dir sage, oder sagen wir mal so, das klassische Beispiel ist, du wirst schwanger und gehst irgendwie einkaufen, dann als Familie und dann fällt dir auf, dass es ganz viele Leute mit Kinderwagen da draußen gibt. Weil das in deinem Leben plötzlich eine wichtige Sache ist. So Kinderkleidung und Kindersachen fällt dir jetzt plötzlich überall auf. Und im weiteren Sinne heißt confirmation Bias eben auch, wenn ich eine These bedenke gerade und ich gucke mir die Welt an und klopfe sie auf diese These ab, dann fallen mir plötzlich Sachen auf, aus dem Kontext dieser These, die ich vorher nicht mit der These in Verbindung gebracht hätte. Und dadurch ergibt sich auf jeden Fall eine Häufung an Beweisen, wenn ich nur mit der Idee schon rangehe. Hier könnte ein pädophilen Ring sein in diesem Fall zum Beispiel. Und dann suche ich irgendwie nach Symbolen, die aussehen, als könnten sie aus diesem Handbuch kommen. Dann finde ich die auch. Ja, so funktioniert unser Gehirn.
Ja, und diese Mechanismen sind natürlich auch relativ mächtig, weil wir, wenn wir uns erinnern, dann gibt es ja irgendwie so im Wesentlichen so die die bekannten, wenigen Mechanismen. Und die beiden wichtigsten davon sind, die neuen Fakten passen zu dem, was wir schon wissen. Also die sind halt irgendwie, die passen zu unserem Weltbild, zu unserer, also die sind einsortierbar. Und das zweite, da sind Dinge an die wir uns erinnern, die mit einer hohen emotionalen Intensität verbunden sind. Also wo es halt irgendeine emotion gibt, die da halt dran attached ist, so. Und daraus folgt natürlich, dass halt solche Fake-News-Dinger, die halt darauf designed sind, nämlich es passt in dein Weltbild so, wenn du hier das annimmst und das annimmst, dann folgt daraus logisch das. Und es ist halt irgendwie diese Schweine. Dann hast du natürlich irgendwie quasi den perfekten Sturm dafür.
Es gibt noch einen anderen Effekt, der verwandt ist. Wenn ich mir eine Sache angucke, dann fokussiere ich meine Aufmerksamkeit darauf. Und mein Hirn nimmt automatisch an, dass diese Sache sehr wichtig ist, weil sonst würde ich da ja nicht meine Zeit mit verplempern. Das heißt, Sachen, mit denen ich mich beschäftige, auch weil ich gerade an der Bushaltestelle vielleicht habe und einfach Langeweile hab, bis der Bus kommt, Sachen, die ich mir in der Zeit angucke, wirken völlig überproportional wichtig auf mich selbst in der Zeit. Und deswegen ist Werbung an Bushaltestellen effektiv.
Krass, ne?
Und das ist ein Mechanismus, den muss man verstanden haben. Und dann muss man sich selbst dabei beobachten, wie man ihm erliegt. Denn die Leute reden sich immer ein, Werbung funktioniert bei mir nicht. funktioniert bei dir, sonst würden die Leute da nicht so viel Geld für ausgeben. confirmation Bias kann man gut bei sich beobachten. Das ist dasselbe, wie wenn ich sage, denk jetzt mal nicht an Wahl. Dann wird es dir einfach sehr schwer fallen, nicht an Wahl zu denken. Ja, so funktioniert es einfach. Das sind Sachen, die kann man verstehen und dann kann man versuchen, gegenzusteuern. Und insbesondere kann man dann verstehen, wieso irgendjemand irgendwas plötzlich sehr wichtig findet. Wenn jemand irgendwie zwei Tage damit verbringt, hinter Pizza Gate herzuklicken, dann wird für ihn die Sache schon, dadurch, dass er dahinter geklickt hat, einen ganz anderen Stellenwert haben als für jemanden, dem das noch nicht begegnet ist. Nicht nur, weil er es nicht gehört hat, sondern auch als rückblickende Rechtfertigung dafür, dass er viel Zeit investiert zu haben.
Ja, dieser Mechanismus wirkt sich natürlich auch immer aus dabei, wenn Leute versuchen, irgendwie Argumente zu bringen. Weil ihnen natürlich die Sachen, auf die sie sich gerade fokussiert haben, das Argument, was sie halt irgendwie gerade geschärft haben, erscheint ihnen natürlich immer als das Wichtigste.
Das kann man übrigens auch ausnutzen, wenn man jemandem was erklärt, indem man erst Kontext schafft.
Genau, also den Fokus auf eine bestimmte Gruppe von Fakten richtet.
Wenn ich jetzt einfach nur irgendwie ein Argument bringe, dann wirkt es weniger gut, als wenn ich vorher fünf Minuten Kontext erkläre. Weil dann habe ich nämlich fünf Minuten lang Bonusaufmerksamkeit eingesammelt und plötzlich wirkt das Argument viel besser. Das heißt, Leute, die irgendwie endlos rumschwafeln und nicht zum Punkt kommen, sind nicht unbedingt doof.
Hängt davon ab, was sie schwafeln.
Ja, das kommt ganz drauf an. Also wenn es zielgerichtet und wenn es nicht einfach rumhäandert, sondern zielgerichtet auf ein Thema abzielt, da muss man sehr vorsichtig sein. Es gibt ein neues Buch von dem Kerldini, von dem wir schon mal ein anderes Buch empfohlen hatten. Das ist pre-swation. pre-swation, genau. Das werde ich auch mal in die Linkliste tun. Der erklärt das auch ganz gut.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich interessant.
Das nennt man z.B. Priming, wenn ich einfach anfange, Leute darauf vorzubereiten, dass ich gleich ein schönes Argument bringen möchte. Unter anderem durch sowas, was ich gerade beschrieben habe, aber es gibt auch andere Mechanismen. So, was haben wir noch auf der Liste? Ich habe hier noch die OPEC.
Genau, noch ein paar News aus dem Ausland, wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind.
Das könnte wirklich eine Zeitenwende sein. Das war mein Eindruck, dass das völlig unterreportet ist, von der Wichtigkeit her.
Also was da passiert ist, ist, die OPEC hat sich offenbar mit Russland darauf geeinigt, also die Arabien hat sich mit Russland darauf geeinigt, und die OPEC hat nachgezogen, dass der Ölpreis mal wieder hoch muss. Und der Grund ist einfach, dass eigentlich alle ölproduzierenden Länder, mit Ausnahme der USA, haben ein massives Interesse daran, dass der Ölpreis jetzt langsam mal wieder irgendwie sich in Höhen bewegt, wo sie ihren Haushalt ausgleiten können.
Na ja, Moment, wieso ist er denn überhaupt niedrig gewesen? Das müssen wir glaube ich zuerst erklären.
Niedrig gewesen ist, weil die Saudis gepumpt haben, was ging so und die...
Und auf Bitten der Amis.
So die Verschwörungstheorie ist halt irgendwie, dass sie halt, also dass es halt irgendwie ein Plot war, wo die Amis und die Saudis zusammen halt irgendwie die Russen pleite machen wollten.
Nicht nur die Russen, auch den Iran.
Und den Iran, ja, stimmt.
Also das Interessante ist, dass im Moment...
Und wie eine Zuhilfe...
.die Russen das so darstellen, als sei ihr Einfluss nur gewesen, zwischen dem Iran und Saudi-Arabien zu verhandeln. Zu vermitteln. Und ich glaube auch, dass da sogar eine Kernwahrheit dran ist. Weil der Iran hat sich ja mit den Amerikanern vor kurzem einigen können. Die haben diesen Deal gemacht. Und das heißt, der offizielle Grund dafür, warum der Ölpreis niedrig sein musste, nämlich um den Iran Platz zu machen, ist damit vom Tisch. Jetzt geht es nur noch um die Russen. Und die Russen sind tatsächlich, haben ihre Reserve...
Und Venezuela.
Und Venezuela, ja, aber das ist...
Die sind schon im Eimer.
Die sind schon im Grunde weg, ne?
Naja, also für die könnte es gerade noch so knapp reichen. Wenn der Ölpreis wieder hoch geht.
Also die... Ja, wenn der Ölpreis wieder hoch geht. Okay, aber die Russen sind jedenfalls ziemlich durch ihre Reserven gegangen in der Niedrigpreiszeit und sind jetzt eigentlich... Haben schon ihre Rentenzurücklagen, Fonds angegangen und so.
Die sind halt schon relativ... Die sind an der Kante.... an der Kante so. Die haben jetzt für nächstes Jahr angesagt, dass sie ihre Militärausgabendramasch zurückfahren, weil der Ölpreis so niedrig ist und so. Also bei den Russen war es jetzt halt so... Also meine Verschwörungstheorie dazu war ja, dass die Russen halt hinsaulich gesagt haben, so passt auf. Ist ja gut und schön jetzt irgendwie mit dem niedrigen Ölpreis gewesen. Aber erstens tut es euch auch weh und zweitens, wenn das dazu führt, dass euer Land destabilisiert wird, wenn wir uns sozusagen nicht darauf einigen können, dass... ja, so. Und ich glaube, dass das, was da in Amiland passiert ist, also dass die Russen halt gezeigt haben, dass sie halt in so einem Land mit irgendwie durchaus moderaten Mitteln halt irgendwie politisch einigermaßen doll was bewegt bekommen.
Oh, du meinst, die haben den saulich gesagt, ey, wir könnten auch bei euch mal ein bisschen...
Ich glaube, das schon. Also ich glaube schon, dass... Also ich glaube schon, so die... So, das gab da so zwei Wege, so, oder? Und der eine Weg war halt so, wir einigen uns jetzt auf einen höheren Ölpreis und der andere Weg wäre gewesen...
Schöne Regierung habt ihr da, mei, ja schade...
.wäre jetzt halt irgendwie über... So übermorgen macht RT Saudi-Arabia auf, so und wir haben übrigens den Satelliten schon in Place oder so, ne? Und das... also ich glaube schon, dass das, das wäre halt der Plan B der Russen gewesen, beziehungsweise ist immer noch der Plan B, wenn der Ölpreis nicht hochgeht. Weil dann Saudi-Arabien zu destabilisieren, ist der letzte logische Move, ne? Also weil...
Naja, also das Interessante ist ja, dass Russland eigentlich niemand destabilisiert hat. Das heißt, das ist jetzt die Gehbewegung gegen... Eigentlich haben die Amis seit vielen Jahren rum destabilisiert im Nahen Osten, weil das Teil von der eurasischen Strategie war, um den Russen Ärger zu machen damals noch, als...
Ja, aber das bezog sich halt auf die Länder, die halt irgendwie nah an der sowjetunion waren.
Ja, aber der Punkt ist doch, dass Russland jetzt anfängt, irgendwelche Länder zu destabilisieren. Das ist ein relativ neues Phänomen.
Genau. Also ich meine, das ist halt... Also wenn wir mal zurückgucken, hat das eigentlich angefangen nach der Ukraine.
Ja.
Na also nachdem der Westen gesagt hat, übrigens, das können wir auch so mal hier so unser Land destabilisieren vor eurer Haustür und...
Na gut, Georgien kann man auch...
Georgien war eher so ein Manöver-Trial für beide Seiten, glaub ich.
Na, da haben sie aber auch schon die Mittel ausprobiert und geschafft.
Da haben sie ausprobiert, genau. Und dann hat der Westen halt dann mit seinem Colored revolution-support den Russen quasi die Ukraine weggenommen. Und dazu muss man verstehen, dass die Russen brauchen halt die Ukraine. Die Ukraine ist halt einfach deren Pufferzone zum Westen. Das ist halt das, wo sie halt irgendwie die Panzerarmeen der NATO, also aus ihrer Sicht, so zu sagen aus der russischen mit der strategischen Denke, ist die Ukraine die Zone, wo sie halt die Panzerarmeen der NATO stoppen, bevor sie in Moskau sind. Und dass die NATO eben das jetzt halt weggenommen hat und sie halt dazu gezwungen hat, dass sie halt irgendwie sich die Krim halt, also ihr Urlaubsparadies da halt wiederholen und nach diesen stressigen Konflikten halt in der Ostukraine halt irgendwie am Laufen halten, das haben die denen nicht verziehen. Und aus meiner Sicht ist das, was die Russen in Ameland gespielt haben, war einfach die eiskalte Rache dafür.
Da das Highlight fand ich ja jetzt nach der Trump-Wahl, dass irgendwie rauskam, die Russen haben in Moskau eine Konferenz gesponsert für die separatisten, Bewegung aus Texas und Kalifornien und irgendwie Baskenland.
Die haben alle diese separatisten Bewegungen eingeladen.
Das ist natürlich der Wink mit dem Zaunfall in den Westen. Das können wir auch.
So, das war halt echt unweise vom Westen, diese Nummer zu fahren.
Vor allem mit Ansageunweise. Das ging ja damals schon los mit...
Genau, war nicht so, dass die Russen nicht gesagt hatten.
Wenn ihr jetzt hier anfangen würdet, ist ein einziges Told you so, was die Russen machen. Das ist eigentlich richtig tragisch, weil die Amis da...
Ich meine, man muss halt natürlich sagen, andersrum ist natürlich unter reinem Demokratie- und Freiheitsaspekten, ist es natürlich so, dass das halt nicht für die Ukraine jetzt nicht der beste Weg ist, als russischer Vasallenstaat zu vergammeln. Aber geostrategisch...
Aber das hättest du ja auch mit offen Verhandlungswege den Status verbessern können. Ist ja nicht so, dass die Russen haben ja kein Interesse daran, dass der Ukraine scheiße geht. Im Gegenteil, die Russen hätten gerne, dass die Ukraine selbstständig in der Lage ist, ihren Gaspreis zu bezahlen.
Ja, genau. Na gut, also jedenfalls der Ölpreis, die Ölpreisentwicklung wird halt sehr interessant. Meine Vorhersage ist, wenn der Ölpreis sich jetzt über den Winter, sagen wir mal in den nächsten 3, 4 Monaten, nicht substanziell nach oben bewegt, also irgendwas Richtung 1,70 $, 1,80 $, so, dann könnte durchaus sein, dass die Russen sagen, naja, das hat jetzt wohl nicht geholfen, wir müssen mal zurück zum Plan B.
Naja, aber dass sie überhaupt Bewegungen in die OPEC gebracht haben, das ist, fand ich, eine relativ krasse Nummer.
Ich würde sagen, die haben in Amiland ihr Waffeninstrumentarium klar zeigen können und dann sind da doch ein paar Leute ins Nachdenken gekommen, ob sie sich damit anlegen wollen. Weil eine richtige Defense dagegen gibt es ja nicht. Ich meine, das ist ja das, was die Deutschen gerade so nervös macht. Die Russen jetzt halt anfangen... Die deutsche Wölle wird jetzt hier zurückfließen. Momentan sind die Abwehrstrategien des Westens gegen russische Propagandavensiven lame und langweilig. Es ist lustigerweise eine Umkehrung von dem, wie es früher zu kalten Kriegszeiten war, wo Rias halt die Coolen waren, die mit der coolen Mucke und irgendwie dem...
Ja, bei ihnen war es schon damals nicht so cool.
Na, der Rias war der...
The Voice of America.
Der hardcore-Propagandasender.
Absolut entsetzlich.
Ja, aber die waren ja trotzdem cool. Das war das, was du im Osten gehört hast, weil da lief halt die coole Musik. Und jetzt ist es halt genau umgekehrt, dass halt irgendwie die, für eine bestimmte Demografie im Westen, halt quasi die gucken halt alle RT, weil RT ist das halt, die halt ein bisschen hip sind und halt die Sachen bringen, die halt irgendwie sich die Menschen im Westen nicht trauen zu bringen oder die sie verpassen oder auf die sie halt keinen Bock haben. Und dann spinnen die denen. Also wie gerade diese Geschichte mit dem, was Straßenbahnfahrer wirft, türkisches Mädchen wegen Kopftuch aus der Bahn.
Gut, das war interessanterweise kein RT-Spin, sondern das war die Pressemitteilung der Polizei.
Ja, aber Moment, was da passiert ist, die Berliner Polizei hat die initiale Pressemeldung gebracht. Daraufhin kamen diese Meldungen auch in allen deutschen Zeitungen. Dann haben sie sich die Videos angeguckt, haben den Busfahrer befragt, der gesagt, ich hab die rausgeschmissen, weil sie einen Döner gegessen hat und nach dreimaliger Aufforderung nicht rausgegangen ist. Was er halt mit jedem anderen auch tun würde, egal ob Kopftuch oder nicht. Das ist ein Berliner Busfahrer, das heißt die ganze Zeit.
Was übrigens vielen Leuten außerhalb Berlins gar nicht klar ist. Ich hab ein paar Zuschriften gekriegt von Leuten, ja wie ein Döner, das machen die doch hier auch immer.
Ja, in Berlin fliegst du, aber wenn sie dich sehen, bist du da aber ganz schnell drauf. Genau, du fliegst halt raus. Und RT hat die Meldung mit dem Kopftuch noch an dem Tag, als die Korrektur schon überall in den deutschen Medien lief, haben die die noch ohne Korrektur immer schön weiter durchgebügelt. Also deren Spin ist halt schon ziemlich professionell, muss man sagen. Naja, das wird halt noch spannend für die Wahlen. Ich denke, die große Frage ist halt natürlich, was passiert jetzt halt weiter in der Flüchtlingskrise? Und da ist es halt so, dass die Abhängigkeit von der Türkei jetzt natürlich dramatisch wird. Also wir haben jetzt die situation, dass die Türkei halt irgendwie ihre Mauer Richtung Syrien fertig hat. Also die haben da so eine drei Meter hohe Mauer mit Stacheldraht und irgendwie rechtlich Leuten mit Maschinengewehren aufgebaut und lassen halt keine Flüchtlinge aus Syrien mehr durch. Und das ist natürlich eigentlich, kann man schon sagen, durchaus auch zum großen Teil ein europäischer Auftrag. Also wir haben halt irgendwie unsere Mauer dahin ausgelagert. Und meine Theorie dazu ist ja...
Na und wir zahlen noch dafür, oder?
Ja, wir zahlen noch dafür. Also eigentlich ist es Flüchtlingshilfe, aber wahrscheinlich haben sie davon den Beton gekauft. Also meine Theorie ist ja, dass sich die europäische Strategie dahingegen in etwas bewegen wird. Es gab, also der Name, den ich da gewählt habe, ist die Greater Mediterranean Welfare Sphere. Sprich halt eine Mauer, die halt durch Nordafrika gebaut wird, um halt irgendwie Richtung Süden die Flüchtlingsströme aufzuhalten, wo dann halt einfach die Deals mit den nordafrikanischen Ländern und der Türkei gemacht werden, um halt dafür zu sorgen, dass die halt sagen, okay, wir bewachen diese Mauern für euch und wir erschießen die Leute, wenn sie halt versuchen, drüber zu klettern. Und es ist halt soweit weg von europäischen Kameras, dass sich niemand dafür interessiert.
Und die Deals gibt es auch schon aus anderem Grund, weil nämlich zum Beispiel die Franzosen beziehen ja Yellow Cake aus Nordafrika. Das heißt, es gibt schon Beziehungen zwischen den Ländern, die man da erweitern kann.
Marokko zum Beispiel. Also Marokko hat halt irgendwie die größten Mauer und Wallanlagen, die halt irgendwie auf diesem Planeten so stehen, außer der chinesischen Mauer. Ich glaube, in Länge und Umfang sind die sogar größer. Wir haben dieselbe situation in vielen anderen von diesen Ländern, die halt einfach auch gerade Mauern bauen und Welle bauen. Und dieses Ganze, das kann man noch nicht bauen, das kriegt man noch nicht hin, ist leider totaler Quatsch. Also da sollte man sich nicht irgendwie dazu verleiten lassen, zu glauben, dass man das technisch nicht hinbekommt. Die Frage ist halt nur, wenn man, also in welchem Umfang, man halt irgendwie seinen Willen, Menschenrechte irgendwie zu beachten, irgendwie missachtet und in dem Augenblick, wo man sagt, halt irgendwie Menschenrechte interessieren uns nicht, kann man selbstverständlich Mauern bauen, über die keiner rüberkommt. Also das ist ja nicht, also hat die DDR die Mauer zwischen DDR und Westdeutschland ja deutlich gezeigt. So, das geht halt schon. Ist halt nur eine ultra brutale Angelegenheit und der Westen muss sich dann halt schon die Frage stellen, wie ernst er das halt mit seinen Menschenrechten eigentlich meint. So und diese, diese Frage halt, die man in die Abhängigkeiten, die man sich natürlich begibt mit der Türkei, die wird natürlich noch hochgradig spannend werden, weil wenn die halt das Ventil in der Hand haben, mit der sind nach Belieben halt irgendwie die Stresstemperatur in Europa, also die gefühlte Stresstemperatur, also es geht ja nur um die Wahrnehmung, nach oben drehen können und der, derjenige, der das halt da tut, halt Erdogan halt nun offensichtlich ein, ja, durchaus jetzt nicht unbedingt demokratisch gesünder Regierungschef ist, könnte das halt schon durchaus noch irgendwie dann einigermaßen bizarrer Wahlkampf werden.
Die haben übrigens auch in anderer Hinsicht die, das Ventil in der Hand und zwar die South Stream Pipeline und die, wie ist diese Nabuko Pipeline, die, die waren auch alle durch die Türkei projektiert. Und jetzt der Krieg in Syrien, da geht es ja angeblich auch um eine Pipeline. Also das ist jetzt die Verschwörungstheorie. Eine Pipeline aus Katar und auch eine Öllieferung oder eine Erdgaslieferung aus dem Iran würde durch die Türkei gehen. Das heißt, der gesamte Nahe Osten, das kann man entweder über Schiffe machen und die, also Schifffahrt ist relativ günstig gerade. Da ist es sogar so, dass teilweise Schiffe jetzt um Afrika rumkreisen, um sich die Kanalkosten. Ich finde so, das kann man ja zu sparen. Und es gibt da wohl auch eine Menge Leerraum, aber eine Pipeline ist natürlich noch billiger. Und die würden alle durch die Türkei gehen. Das heißt, wenn der Erdogan uns wirklich anpissen wollte, dann hätte der alle Mittel in der Hand, auch ohne Flüchtlinge.
Tja, naja, also die Theorie bei den amerikanischen Geostrategien ist ja, dass die Türkei als neue Sonate Mittel macht. Also als eine sozusagen nicht Großmacht, aber auch irgendwie nicht Kleinmacht ihre Machtmittel etabliert und dann halt am Ende die außenorganisation halt mit dem Iran und Saudi-Arabien und wahrscheinlich Ägypten um diese Rolle führen wird, aber dabei wahrscheinlich gewinnen wird, also einfach aufgrund von Demografie und ökonomisch und geografischer situation. Das wird auf jeden Fall auch noch spannend, apropos möglichst uninteressanten Zeiten leben.
Also weißt du, wir haben hier angefangen mit der Sendung und dachten, das wird irgendwie eine knappe Stunde. Wie weit sind wir jetzt?
Na ja, knapp zwei.
Doch mehr Material, als wir gedacht haben. Wir haben jetzt hier noch die, was haben wir noch? Nicht viel digitale Karta. Können wir noch kurz anreden?
Genau, digitale Karta. Eher so europäische Innenpolitik.
Was ist denn das überhaupt?
Also was passiert ist, es gab halt schon seit einer Weile, also schon noch als Schömmacher noch lebte, die diskussion darum, ob man nicht eine Erweiterung der europäischen Menschenrechtskarta bräuchte um digitale Aspekte. Also um spezifisch für den digitalen Raum notwendige Grund- und Menschenrechte. Und die diskussion blubberte halt so eine ganze Weile vor sich hin, irgendwie nach Schömmachers Tod, ebte sie halt so ein bisschen ab und kam dann halt aber wieder hoch. Und die grundlegende Idee dabei war zu sagen, okay, wenn man halt mal aufschreibt, was man eigentlich so braucht, als Ideen für so grundlegende Rechte im digitalen Raum, die sowohl gegenüber Staaten, also dem Staat, als auch gegenüber Unternehmen gelten sollen. Das war eigentlich die Neuerung dabei. Man bisher sagte ja, Grundrechte gelten immer nur gegenüber dem Staat. Man sagte, okay, im digitalen Raum sind Unternehmen, Plattformen, Geschäftsmodelle so wichtig, dass man die auch mit einbeziehen muss und halt Grundrechte gegenüber Unternehmen jetzt nicht sozusagen irgendwie nur rein den Gesetzgeber überlassen werden dürfen. Und dann mal anfängt darüber zu diskutieren. Also einfach zusammen, okay, man fängt mal an mit irgendeiner Art von Text. Und dann versucht man darin, möglichst alle Punkte, über die es wahrscheinlich diskussionen und Streit geben wird, mal mit aufzunehmen und stellt sie dann zur öffentlichen diskussion. Und dieser Prozess fing so vor 14 Monaten, 15 Monaten, 14 Monaten fing er an.
Die Zielvorstellung ist sowas wie die menschenrechtskonvention.
Die europäische Menschenrechtskarte war ja eine ursprünglich unverbindliche Absichtserklärung von Staaten, die dann verbindlich wurde. Also nach und nach hat die europäische menschenrechtskonvention einen quasi Gesetzesstatus erreicht, dadurch, dass wir Staaten gesagt haben, ja, finden wir gut, finden wir richtig, finden wir wichtig, halten wir uns dran. Also quasi so, wie sowas eigentlich auch sein sollte. Also entwickelt sich halt sozusagen als ein Kanon gemeinsamer Werte. Und dafür halt irgendwie mal einen Startpunkt zu setzen, damit man irgendwann in fünf Jahren oder so mal da ist und sagt uns, okay, das könnte jetzt irgendwas sein, war halt die Absicht. Und damals hat, also diskussionen gab es halt schon länger so, die mir anderte halt so da zwischen so Netzaktivisten, Journalisten, Autoren, die in dem Bereich unterwegs sind und halt eine Menge Wissenschaftlern, die halt in dem so in diesem ganzen Netzbereich unterwegs sind und die dann irgendwann gab es halt mal so einen Anschluss von der Zeitstiftung, die sagte, okay, lass uns das noch mal versuchen. Also lass uns noch mal versuchen, irgendwie einen Text zusammenzukriegen. Und die haben halt alle Leute eingeladen dazu. Und dabei war halt die klare Absicht zu sagen, okay, wir wollen keine Lobbyisten. Also wir wollen halt keine Leute dabei haben, die halt Interessen von irgendwelchen großen Konzernen vertreten. Weswegen halt auch etliche Leute, die jetzt halt diese entstandene digitale Charta kritisieren, intensiv halt auch nicht eingeladen wurden. Also es ist halt so, weil wir sagten, okay, also auch eines der interessanten Dinge, die ich zum Beispiel gelernt habe, im Rahmen dieser Arbeit, für die es an dieser Charta war, warum sind denn so viele Anwälte eigentlich als Lobbyisten de facto unterwegs, publizistisch? Naja, das Anwaltsgeheimnis, das heißt, die müssen nicht offenlegen, für wen sie unterwegs sind.
Wie viele Leute haben denn da jetzt mitgearbeitet?
Also die ursprüngliche Einnahmungsgruppe waren so 40, am Ende waren es 27, die tatsächlich dann erschienen sind und daran mitgemacht haben. Es gab halt so ein Format, so diverse Sitzungen, wo einzelne Themen diskutiert wurden und dann so ein bisschen Tendenz und so. Und dann gab es halt so eine echtlängliche, umfängliche Textarbeit, die auch nicht so einfach war, weil natürlich die Gruppe sehr divers war. Da sind auch eine Menge Leute dabei waren, die halt dann ihre persönlichen, also was sie persönlich wichtig finden, mit eingebracht haben. Also zum Beispiel so was wie Autoren, die halt sagen, okay, ich finde es halt super wichtig, dass man irgendwas gegen Piracy da reinschreibt, weil sonst kann ich ja nicht leben. So und dann denen halt dann langsam und mühsam erklärt wurde, so pass auf. Wir schreiben hier Grundrechte, wir schreiben hier jetzt nicht halt irgendwie irgendwie gegen Kleinkram, sondern war natürlich das ganze Thema, was jetzt halt auch intensiv diskutiert wird. Hate Speech und ja, diese Geschichten, worüber jetzt halt sicher auch ein Großteil der diskussionen entbrannt hat im Netz. Und da war es halt so, dass die diskussion halt sehr länglich und sehr, sehr, naja, kontrovers war, kann man sagen. Und man sich am Ende darauf geeinigt hat, okay, wir wollen uns nicht auf Mechanismen festlegen. Wir wollen nicht sagen, okay, es muss eine Vorzensur geben oder es muss halt irgendwie eine rechtliche Verpflichtung von Anbietern geben oder was auch immer, sondern es geht halt einfach nur darum, dass wir den die Effekte vermeiden wollen. Also wir wollen halt nicht, dass Leute sich im Netz nicht äußern können, weil sie dann halt einfach von den Shitstorms komplett verbrannt werden. Sondern muss halt irgend einen zumindest gesellschaftlichen Konsens geben. Und daraus resultierte halt dann diese Formulierung, die jetzt halt, wie gesagt, sind zu verhindern, mit der ich persönlich überhaupt nicht glücklich war. Aber dann irgendwann gesagt, pass auf, wir haben jetzt hier schon 14 Monate an diesem Ding rumgeschrieben, wir wollen eh in großem Umfang im Netz diskutieren. So und war auch vollkommen klar, dass das halt irgendwie Leute fürchten werden, dass es halt irgendwie irgendeine Zensur oder sowas gibt. Ich hab versucht zu erklären. Es ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig. Und das Ergebnis war halt zu sagen, okay, das wird sowieso diskutiert werden, die Formulierung wird sowieso nicht bestand haben, wir werden da halt einfach eine, ja, so. Und das Problem war halt jetzt einfach, dass diese diskussion darüber, also dass das halt eine diskussionsgrundlage ist, das wurde halt in der kommunikation in die Zahl überhaupt nicht vermittelt. Also das war halt zu wenig. Scheiße. Na, das war halt, das kam halt so rüber, wie, ähm, das ist jetzt halt beschlossen und jetzt geht's gleich ans Europaparlament und dann wird's durchgewunken. Was halt überhaupt nichts mit der Realität zu tun hat. Also das ist völlig abseitig, ja. Also was halt passiert ist, dass diese Initiative, so wie viele andere Initiativen, ähm, die halt so aus, aus dem intellektuellen Spektrum kommen, vorgestellt wird dem Ausschuss, ne, also dem Lieberausschuss. Der Lieberausschuss irgendwie ist halt so der, der Ausschuss, der halt so für grundlegende Verfassungsfragen in Europa zuständig ist und der irgendwann mal möglicherweise der ist, der sagt, okay, das finden wir vielleicht notwendig. Wir berufen jetzt mal eine europaweite Versammlung, eine Stadt, mal so ein Prozess. Und was man am Montag tun, ist dann halt zu sagen, okay, gibt diese Initiative und hier ist halt mal so ein Text. Wir haben das schon mal übersetzt in verschiedenen Sprachen. Wir würden jetzt gerne mal die diskussion anstoßen, sondern dann wird dieser Ausschuss halt sagen, ach, ist aber schön, dass ihr diese Initiative habt. Finden wir vielleicht ganz gut so. Und dann fangen wir mal die diskussion auch im parlamentarischen Rahmen an, ob man sowas braucht. Also das ist halt so mit nichten, halt so wie es jetzt so gerne dargestellt wird, ja so eine Hinterzimmerkugellei, wo jetzt halt irgendwie sowieso schon alles klar ist.
Hat das denn so ein bisschen traktion? Also konnten wir das von unten weg?
Also momentan gibt es halt eine Menge Kommentare, nachdem Leute verstanden haben, dass man es kommentieren kann. Gibt es halt irgendwie so eine vierstellige Anzahl von Kommentaren, die jetzt auch moderiert werden, also im Sinne von halt irgendwie Rechtschreib korrigiert und halt irgendwie den absoluten Bullshit halt rausfiltern?
Ich glaube, die Webseite hatte, als ich geklickt habe, zumindest noch gar keine Kommentare.
Doch, du kannst jeden Artikel einzeln kommentieren. Du kannst auf jeden Artikel auf die Überschrift klicken und darunter sind die Kommentare.
Okay, das habe ich nicht gemacht.
Und die Idee dabei ist halt einfach zu sagen, so soll jetzt halt nicht im komplett luftleeren Raum starten, sondern jeder Artikel ist halt eine reflektion von langen diskussionen mit vielen Leuten im Sinne von, das ist ein wichtiges Thema. Also das ist halt ein Aspekt, der halt für solche Grund- und Freiheitrechte notwendig ist. Und wie sich jetzt halt in der diskussion schon zeigt, ist es halt total gut, halt mit vielen Leuten zu diskutieren, aber auch eben an so einem konkreten Beispiel, weil daraus neue Ideen entstehen. Zum Beispiel gibt es jetzt halt irgendwie so in den Kommentaren, gibt es jetzt einen so im Strang, der sagt, okay, man hat ein Grundrecht auf Konnektivität, das gehört da eigentlich rein und haben vollkommen Recht. Also es ist halt so zu sagen, so offline sein geht halt eigentlich nicht mehr, also deswegen brauchen wir ein Grundrecht auf Konnektivität, was da natürlich reingehört. Und dieser Entwicklungsprozess, der startet jetzt halt so. Und was mich aber halt persönlich halt so ein bisschen anfrisst bei dieser ganzen Geschichte, ist, dass halt eben, also insbesondere auf Twitter die Leute erstmal grundsätzlich annehmen mit sei böse. Es gibt halt immer diese grundsätzliche Annahme, wenn du für irgendwas bist, das war damals beim Datenbrief ja auch schon so, dass erstmal angenommen wird, das ist nur ein böser Versuch von irgendwelchen fiesen Lobbyisten, ihre Zensur vorhaben irgendwie jetzt auch noch irgendwie durch irgendwie ein Werk von Verfassungsrang zu legitimieren. Und ich denke mir so, Kinder, ihr kennt mich doch, wo würde ich bei so was mitmachen? So würden irgendwie Leute, die irgendwie wie Sascha Lobe oder Johnny Häusler, würden die bei irgendwas mitmachen, wo klar ist, dass es halt irgendwie darum geht, irgendwie für Zensur irgendwie zu werben oder das halt zu legitimieren.
Du, das ist halt, das darf man glaube ich nicht persönlich nehmen. Ich meine, wir haben ja, das können wir vielleicht bei der Gelingheit auch mal erzählen, wir haben uns mal mit der amadeo-antonio-stiftung hier kurz getroffen. Und da kam diese Art von Kritik uns gegenüber. Und das muss ich einfach zur Kenntnis nehmen, dass auch ich mich so verhalte oder es zumindest auf andere so wirkt, dass die irgendwie glauben, fundamental opposition und ich nehme erstmal das Schlimmste an. Und ich glaube, das kommt auch ein bisschen daher, dass wir einfach gewisse Debatten schon seit so vielen Jahren haben, dass einfach jeder Vorstoß erstmal angenommen wird, als okay, das ist hier bestimmt wieder dieselbe Scheiße.
Ja, aber das ist halt genau diese Annahme, dass diese Annahme von Veränderung kann nur zum Schlechten sein.
Ja, also das ist genau was wir...
Genau dieser Punkt. Also genau dieses...
Und es ist doch eine Runde Sendung.
So, diese Veränderung kann nur zum Schlechten sein.
Wenn man sagt, okay, wir stehen einfach alle mit dem Rücken schon so zur Wand, dass wir sagen, nee, also jetzt lieber gar nichts, als hier irgendwas zu riskieren. Keine Experimente so, Adel Dauer.
Genau. Und dabei können wir nur verlieren, weil die Feinde der Freiheit, also die Leute, die halt wirklich Zensur wollen und die Leute, die halt wirklich irgendwie eine autoritäre Gesellschaft wollen, die sind perfekt geübt darin, die Gesetze vorzubereiten, die sie nach dem Terroranschlag durchziehen. Die sind perfekt geübt darin, immer was parat zu haben. Und die liberale Linke kriegt das einfach nicht hin. Die kriegt es einfach nicht hin, zu sagen, was wollen wir denn eigentlich, was sind dann die Grundrechte, die wir haben wollen? Dann sagts doch einfach, schreibts hin, mach einen Vorschlag. So sorg dafür, dass überhaupt eine diskussion beginnen kann, aus der dann irgendwas werden kann. Wenn wir damit nicht anfangen, dann werden wir immer nur den Rechten hinterherrennen. So, und wenn ich mir jetzt angucke, was irgendwie ein Kritik teilweise von irgendwelchen Google Lobby-Vertretern, die irgendwie als U-Boote durch die Berliner Landschaft fliegen, was da teilweise kommt, so die halt dann so mit, ja, ist ja irgendwie so individualistisch so. Na ja, natürlich wollen wir an die Geschäftsmodelle von den Konzernen ran. Natürlich wollen wir halt irgendwie Dinge tun, die halt irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass irgendwie Unternehmen nicht mehr einfach nur ihre Profitinteressen oder Interessen in der Allgemeinheit stellen können. Und wenn das der Kritikpunkt ist, na ja schön, das habt ihr richtig begriffen.
Ja, also ich glaube, ich glaube, so ein bisschen zu erkennen zu können, was ich eigentlich seit Jahren behaupte, dass die Linken so ein bisschen die Konsensfähigkeit verloren haben, weil da einfach zu häufig irgendwie Virtue-Singling getrieben wird. Oder ich bin aber der linkere Linker als du und du bist eigentlich Querfront und einfach schon an kleinsten, an Punkten kleinster Divisivität, also wo man eigentlich derselben Meinung ist. Bis auf so einen kleinen Vitzel reicht aber der kleine Vitzel schon, um lieber Krieg zu führen untereinander, als um sich auf irgendeinen Scheiß zu einigen. Und selbst wenn der jetzt nicht, weißt du, wenn der zu 95 Prozent das ist, was du schon immer haben wolltest und 5 Prozent stimmen nicht, dann ist einfach, bei den Rechten übrigens auch, das sehen wir noch nicht so, aber bei den Linken ist es so, ist mir mehrfach bestätigt worden jetzt, dass die genauso sich in irgendwelchen, und das Problem ist aber, dass die meisten von denen, also was heißt Problem, das Gute ist, dass die meisten von denen einfach überhaupt gar keine Presse, einen Liederschlag finden. Das heißt, wir erfahren das einfach nicht. Genauso wenig, wie wir sehen, wie die planen, sehen wir auch, wie die sich streiten. Das heißt, wir haben einfach insgesamt zu wenig Anliegen.
Also du glaubst, dass das nicht ein spezifisches Merkmal der Linken ist?
Das ist kein spezifisches Merkmal der Linken, aber bei den Linken ärgert es mich halt besonders, weil ich mich da zugehörig gefühle. Und ich glaube, das ist ein generelles Problem, auch durch diese Filterblasen. Dadurch, dass ich es auf Facebook erfahren kann oder auf Twitter, dass ich eine derartig krasse Übereinstimmung zwischen dem, was ich sehen will und dem, was ich tatsächlich sehe, erreichen kann, ist das, also ich illustriere das mal an Spam-Bekämpfungen, weil da ist es für mich sehr deutlich. Wenn ich irgendwie normalerweise 100 Mails kriege und davon sind 50 Spam und ich mache jetzt ein Spam-Filter und kriege nur noch drei Spam, dann ärgere ich mich über die drei Spam mehr, als ich mich vorher über die 50 geärgert habe, weil ich jetzt nämlich was unternommen habe und das Gefühl habe, die sind bösartig. Vorher waren die nur so, naja, die kommen halt rein. Aber diese drei, die haben irgendwas gemacht, die haben irgendwas gemacht, um meine Maßnahme zu umgehen. Und ich glaube, dass das generell so ein Effekt ist, den man hat. Wenn ich sehe, okay, also hier kann ich 100 Prozent Übereinstimmung haben und wenn ich aber mit dem Typ da rede, dann habe ich nur noch 98 Prozent, dann ärgere ich mich, glaube ich, völlig überproportional über die zwei Prozent. Anstatt zu sagen, 98 Prozent Übereinstimmung, ja, wir könnten irgendwie zusammen eine Partei aufmachen. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch ein Effekt dieser Filterblase.
Ja, ich glaube, ein anderer Effekt ist halt auch, dass die Leute einander nicht mehr zubelegen, dass sie, obwohl man möglicherweise in dem einen oder anderen Punkt halt nicht übereinstimmt, man doch halt irgendwie ansonsten relativ große Gemeinsamkeiten hat. Die Leute unterstellen allen anderen Leuten immer nur das Böse.
Auch, dass jemand eine valide position haben könnte, die anders ist als eine selbst andere Sache, wo ich noch keine positionen habe. Kann ich häufig beobachten, dass einfach Leute sagen, okay, also ich weiß zwar nicht, was richtig ist, aber das ist bestimmt falsch. Man ist viel eher bereit zu sagen, das ist alles scheiße, als zu sagen, das guck ich mir mal an, vielleicht hat er ja Hand und Fuß.
Also, nehmen wir mal wieder dieses Beispiel, irgendwie diese Hate Speech und Rufschädigungsgeschichte. Das ist halt so ein Ding, was eine Leute emotional trifft. Das war halt auch in dieser Runde so. Da gab es halt Leute, die hatten halt einfach mal die Inbox voll mit irgendwelchen Nazis. Das kommt halt vor. Die wollen halt, dass irgendwas dagegen getan wird. Das kann ich mir vollständig verstehen. Trotzdem sind das halt nicht Leute, die sagen, jetzt will ich aber eine ordentliche Wortsensor haben. Sondern es ist halt so ein Mechanismus zu sagen, wir wollen halt, dass irgendwas getan wird. Deswegen ist es ein wichtiges Thema, über das wir diskutieren müssen. Vielleicht finden wir in dieser diskussion einfach auch Mechanismen. Vielleicht finden wir Wege, rechtsstaatliche Mittel zu sagen, okay, wir brauchen halt möglicherweise sowas wie spezielle Gerichte dafür, vor denen du halt rechtsstaatlich deine Rechte im Netz einklagen kannst. Und nicht diese Scheiße, wie sie jetzt passiert hat, mit dem Recht auf vergessen, wo de facto irgendwo bei Google irgendein Komitee sagt, naja, klick weg. Oder wo du halt irgendwie dann irgendwelche Callcenter...
Ohne Rechtsweg dagegen?
Ohne Rechtsweg, ohne irgendwas. Ich meine, wir haben ja gerade die situation zum Beispiel, dass die YPG, also die syrischen Kurden, die finden auf YouTube quasi nicht statt, weil sie halt von Leuten aus der Türkei, die halt vom Staat offenbar bezahlt werden, permanent gefleckt werden als irgendwie...
Anstößig.
Anstößig oder violence oder was auch immer. Und die haben halt große Mühe, halt irgendwie überhaupt ihre positionen rauszubekommen. Die schaffen es auch mal wieder. Aber sobald da eine kurdische Fahne oder ein Edgerland-Portrait oder so irgendwie im Bild ist, ist sofort Terrorismus. Und diese Mechanismen auf die Anbieter zu verlagern, ist natürlich völliger Quatsch. Also ich meine, das kann halt nicht funktionieren. Wir müssen uns halt überlegen, wie modernisieren wir den Rechtsstaat so, dass er in der Lage ist, mit seinen rechtsstaatlichen Mitteln halt nicht Monate zu brauchen, um solche Entscheidung zu wählen. Deshalb...
Lass mich mal die Vermutung äußern, dass es in vielen Fällen auch akzeptabel wäre, wenn wir in der diskussion zu dem Ergebnis kommen, dass es deine individuelle Aufgabe ist, deine Inbox zu löschen, wenn da Scheiße reinkommt. Ich glaube, da könnten viele Leute auch mit leben, also jetzt nicht in allen Fällen. Aber bevor die anfangen, einfach Sachen zu löschen, hätten die gerne den Konsens hergestellt, dass das der Weg ist, den wir jetzt gehen wollen. Ich glaube, viele Leute, die laut über Internetzensur nachdenken, die wollen eigentlich gar nicht Zensur. Wenn du mit denen redest und wenn du denen erklärst, was das für ein Rattenschwanz an Problemen hinter sich herzieht, dann gibt es doch keinen, der sich hinschaut und sagt, ja ich will aber trotzdem Zensur haben.
Ich meine selbst die Marien-Thierry-Leute ja nicht.
Ja, nein, die wollten natürlich auch keine Zensur. Die waren total...
Die waren verblüfft davon, dass...
Die waren verblüfft, dass ihnen jemand vorgeworfen wird. Ja, genau.
Und die waren, also das war auch sehr interessant, dass die halt einfach auch nicht, also denen war nicht klar, wie hart dieser Zensurvorwurf halt die digitale Szene triggert. Die kannten zwar so diese ganze Zensursaler-Geschichte, so am Rande, so die Netzsperrgeschichte.
Ja, vom Vorbeifahren, aber nur.
Aber so vom Vorbeifahren, das haben die nicht auf sich bezogen.
Und haben auch nicht verstanden, dass die Leute einfach das Gefühl haben werden, okay, also pass auf, jetzt kommt hier der nächste und will Zensur, der kriegt jetzt auf die Fresse. Und das ist ihnen ja im Großen passiert, so kamen wir das jedenfalls vor. Und also die wollten alle nichts Böses. Auch diese ganzen Nazi-Pranger-Geschichten meinen die gut, aber du musst halt beide Seiten mal erlebt haben, irgendwie, du musst mal sehen, wie das ist, wenn so ein Pranger irgendwo läuft und du stehst drauf. Und interessanterweise ist das ja einigen Leuten von den Amadeus auch passiert, dass die auf irgendwelchen Pranger an der Rechten standen. Die wissen also, dass das scheiße ist. Und haben aber trotzdem irgendwie den Sprung nicht gekriegt, zu sagen, na dann machen wir auch keine Pranger, sondern dann erst Recht. Also das ist eine Sache, die mich auch seit einer Weile beschäftigt. Eigentlich im Großteil, seit wir dieses Gespräch mit denen hatten, so wie Leute es schaffen, ihr eigenes Tun zu relativieren, dadurch, dass sie sagen, was die anderen machen, ist aber noch schlimmer. Also das ist ja gerade, wenn beide eigentlich essentiell dasselbe machen wie diese Pranger, dann ist es ja gar nicht so einfach, da eine argumentation zu finden, dass die anderen das aber schlimmer machen. Und die argumentation in dem Fall war, dass mit den Nazis eben auch Gewaltaufrufe verbunden seien. Und wir machen das ja nur zu Doku-Zwenken. Und das ist eigentlich ein sehr schmaler Steig, auf dem man da steht, wenn man so argumentiert, finde ich. Weil du kannst ja nicht die Verantwortung übernehmen für irgendwelche anderen Leute, die bei dir den Pranger sehen und dann losziehen und Gewalt ausüben.
Genau dieser Punkt zum Beispiel, also diese Internet-Pranger-Geschichte spielt hat und das ist gesungen, weil dieser Digital-Krater durchaus auch eine Rolle ist. Das ist also auch ein wichtiger Punkt, was zu sagen, vielleicht muss man solche Digital-Pranger einfach verbieten und zwar egal in welche Richtung.
Und egal, ob die inhaltlich Recht haben oder nicht.
Ja, also möglicherweise. Das wäre ein wichtiger Punkt. Also einfach zu sagen, dass so Personen...
Die Würde des Menschen wird verletzt durch so ein Pranger, also findet ja nicht statt.
Punkt ja nicht statt. So, ne. Und das ist halt, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, das ist Zensur. Das kann man ja durchaus sagen, aber es ist halt eine Einschränkung deiner Meinungsaussorgung. Wenn man aber sagen muss, okay, aber die tatsächlich diese, das Bedürfnis, jemand vollständig zu dokumentieren, was ja so in Fortschneidung Linguotoxin heißt, um ihm indirekt einen Schaden zufügen zu können. Und darum geht's ja. Also weil dann hofft man, dass irgendjemand vorbeigeht und ihn aufs Maul haut oder so. Oder ihm, der nicht angestellt wird oder von seinem Arbeitgeber rausgebracht wird.
Aber das rationalisieren sich die Leute weg, den Teil davon.
Sowohl die Rechten als auch die Linken.
Ja, natürlich.
Und dazu sagen, okay, aber das ist tatsächlich eine Art von Umgang mit dem Internet, den wir vielleicht, müssen wir diskutieren, möglicherweise einfach verbieten müssen.
Ich finde das auch durchaus gleichzusetzen mit Gewaltausübungen. Also es gibt ja auch, auch bei Gewalt sind wir inzwischen soweit zu sagen, es gibt körperliche Gewalt und es gibt aber auch andere Arten von Gewalt, irgendwie jemanden beleidigen. Und dass man einfach sagt, Daten gegen den Willen desjenigen zu erheben oder zu veröffentlichen, ist auch schon Gewalt. Es ist halt eine digitale Gewalt. Und also ich empfinde das persönlich als Gewalt, wenn Leute von mir Daten haben wollen, die ihnen nicht zustehen. Das ist ein Versuch, über meine Souveränität, über den Umgang mit meinen eigenen Daten zu verletzen. Und das geht mir bei der Meldestelle so, wenn die irgendwie die Fingerabdrücke für den Pass haben wollen, das empfinde ich als massiven Eingriff in meine persönliche Souveränität. Und das geht mir aber auch bei irgendwelchen Webseiten so, die gerne meine E-Mail-Adresse und meine Telefonnummer haben wollen. Das muss einfach mal angesprochen werden, dass die Souveränität der Daten ist vielleicht nicht ganz so wichtig wie die Unverletztheit des Körpers. Aber es ist auch eine Form von Gewalt. Das muss man zumindest mal so diskutieren können. Und die CARTA versucht also diese Art von diskussion jetzt loszutreten.
Genau. Darum geht es halt einfach zu sagen, was sind denn die Dinge, die wir digital netzspezifisch regeln müssen, die wir nicht den Gerichten überlassen können, das aus den allgemeinen Grundrechten herzuleiten. Das war halt so die Überlegung dabei. Und diese diskussion läuft auch gerade jetzt. Und ich würde es gut finden, wenn ihr euch daran beteiligt. Also auch einfach wohl wissend, dass auf der anderen Seite, da halt in der Gruppe, die halt diese Formulierungen gewählt haben, sitzen halt auch Leute, die haben halt einfach, die sind halt einfach ein bisschen älter, die haben halt andere Herangehensweisen, andere Sichtweisen. Jeder dieser Formulierungen ist ein Kompromiss, der halt gewählt wurde, um einen Flock einzuschlagen, im Sinne von, das ist ein Thema, was wichtig ist. Nicht diese konkrete Formulierung ist jetzt die, die da unbedingt dran landen muss, sondern dieser Themenbereich ist einer, über den wir mal reden müssen, wo wir als Gesellschaft einen Konsens finden müssen.
Man sieht auch ganz gut, wie breit das Spektrum der Leute ist, die da mitgemacht haben. An dem einen Punkt, den ich erst mal googeln musste, da ging es nämlich um das Recht des Nichtwissens.
Auf Nichtwissen, ja.
Und da musste ich erst mal googeln, was das überhaupt sein soll. Und Nichtwissen, damit ist gemeint, wenn jetzt ein Arzt eine Blutprobe nimmt und findet irgendwie, was weiß ich, HIV oder Krebs oder so. Oder, also ich glaube, Krebs ist ein gutes Beispiel, so nach dem Motto, du hast noch zwei Wochen oder irgendwie ein Jahr oder so. Und du müsstest jetzt dein Leben umstellen, wenn ich dir das sage. Ob du dann das Recht hast, als Patient zu sagen, das würde ich aber nicht wissen.
Oder noch viel, da kommt dieses Konzept her. Viel umfänglicher, wenn aus Daten, die zufällig über dich bekannt sind, zum Beispiel halt DNA-Daten deiner Verwandten, oder Lebensumständen, die sich zum Beispiel aus der Beobachtung von digitalen Assistenten auf dem Telefon ergeben, Schlussfolgen gezogen werden können, die dich in deiner Lebensruhe halt beeinträchtigen, dass du halt sagen kannst, ich will nicht wissen, das interessiert mich nicht. Also du kannst halt mittlerweile, zum Beispiel gibt es eine Studie, die sagt, du kannst aus der Beobachtung von wie Leute laufen, also Schrittart und so, kannst du halt bestimmte Formen von Alzheimer und Demenz vorhersagen. Schon eine Weile vorher.
Ach du meine Güte.
Ja genau.
Das heißt, am Flughafen könnten sie dir sozusagen...
Nee, musst du schon länger beobachten... .könnte immer so. Aber eine App auf dem Telefon könnte es halt irgendwie... Wie gut die koalition ist, wissen wir noch nicht, aber das sind halt so Beispiele von Sachen, wo man sagen muss, okay. Andererseits wäre halt die gesellschaftliche Lösung zu sagen, das Kollektiv hat ein Recht darauf zu wissen, dass du demnächst dement wirst, damit sie dich rechtzeitig medikamentieren kann.
Und damit du nicht Präsident wirst.
Genau, möglicherweise ist aber deine persönliche Präferanz zu sagen, naja Gott, wenn ich halt wegdämmer, dann rieche ich halt weg. Ja, kann ja sein. Diese diskussionen wurden halt eben auch geführt, auch auf einer intellektuell sehr hohen Ebene. Und jetzt sind nicht alle Formulierungen, die dabei rauskommen, super optimal.
Das ist ja auch nicht das Ziel gewesen.
Das ist halt auch ein Kompromisswerk aus einer großen Gruppe, mit dem Ziel zu sagen, okay, wir wollen halt die Themen festsetzen oder zumindest mal so den Rahmen umreißen, in dem wir diskutieren wollen. Und dazu gehört unter anderem halt eben auch diese hatspeech-doxing-rufschädigungsdiskussion, die wir halt einfach mal führen müssen. Und wo wir jetzt halt nicht irgendwie in unseren Lagern verharren dürfen und sagen dürfen, okay, wenn du irgendwas machen willst und irgendwas verbieten willst, dann ist es aber Zensur. Also wie wir jetzt gerade dieses Doxing-Beispiel zum Beispiel hatten, wo man sagen kann, okay, möglicherweise ist es im reinen Meinungsäußerungssinne, ist es Zensur, wenn das halt verboten ist, Profile von Menschen zu publizieren. Aber der Schaden für den Einzelnen ist möglicherweise so groß, dass man sagen kann, okay, den Schritt müssen wir möglicherweise machen. Und die diskussion darüber müssen wir führen. Die gesellschaftliche Debatte darüber kann nicht länger vertagt werden. Und dafür ist diese Karte da.
Gibt es denn da, also wird es schon geben, wie ist denn die Struktur, in der sich jetzt die diskussion weiterentwickeln soll? Gibt es da irgendwelche Meilensteine oder so?
Also was momentan passiert ist, die Kommentare werden auf dieser Webseite gesammelt. Da geht es halt erst mal nur darum, erst mal zu gucken, wie groß ist mein Spektrum. Und der nächste Schritt ist noch nicht klar. Also der ist halt einfach noch nicht festgelegt.
Okay.
Auch einfach deswegen, weil wir diesen Prozess halt eben auch nicht so sehr bestimmen wollen. Also es geht halt jetzt auch nicht darum zu sagen, so hier ist jetzt der Meilenstein, irgendwie am 25. Januar muss der Text fertig sein, damit er halt da verabschiedet werden kann und die Übersetzung alles klar ist. Sondern es ist halt eher so ein Punkt zu sagen, okay, das geht jetzt in dem Lieberausschuss, gibt es halt diese Vorstellungen im Europaparlament, damit die auch mal anfangen zu diskutieren und sich zu überlegen, was sind denn die Themen, die wichtig sind. Dann gibt es halt die Übersetzungen in die anderen Sprachen. Dann geht es halt auch da in die diskussion. Ich meine, das ist eine europäische, also die Idee ist, eine europäische Krater zu finden. Dann wird es wahrscheinlich einen Tool geben, wo halt man mal alle Kommentare und vor allen Dingen auch alle Pro- und Contra-Argumente strukturiert sammelt, um halt einfach mal so auch das aufzubauen. Dann muss man halt überlegen, wie man halt das ganze Ding demokratisch legitimiert bekommt. Also ob man es halt zum Beispiel zur Abstimmung stellt oder wie auch immer. Das sind halt auch schwierige Fragen, also die halt auch mit der Grundlage der demokratischen legitimation zu tun haben und die halt nach und nach halt irgendwie sich entwickeln werden. So und die Frage, welche Staaten dann halt überhaupt akzeptieren als ihr Ding oder sagen, ok, diese Grundrechte greifen wir mit auf oder die erkennen wir an oder so, ist auch noch völlig ungeklärt. Also das ist halt so, mit worum es geht, ist halt erst mal überhaupt eine positive Debatte zu führen, zu sagen, wir brauchen neue Grundrechte, wir müssen diese Grundrechte festlegen. So wir müssen dazu nicht die Verfassung ändern, sondern wir können die ebenso wie die europäische Menschenrechtscharta aufsetzen und sagen, wir wollen halt einfach mal positiv darüber diskutieren, was halt irgendwie neue Grundrechte sind. Und ich meine, wenn ihr meint, irgendwie Leute im Internet beleidigen zu können, ist halt irgendwie ein fundamentales Grundrecht so, dann schreibt es doch hin. Vielleicht sind ja auch mehr Leute dieser Meinung. Das ist ja durchaus möglich. Es ist halt nicht so, dass halt irgendwie an dieser Stelle halt ein Konsens ist. Wir haben da halt natürlich einen großen Konflikt zwischen der, sagen wir mal, dem europäischen Gedanken halt irgendwie, was irgendwie Meinungsfreiheit angeht und dem Deutschen, der ja noch deutlich eingeschränkt ist und dem amerikanischen Modell, der halt sagt, ok, ungefähr geht alles außer, ich kann dich vor dem Gericht auf Schadenversatz verklagen. Ja, wenn es, muss man ja mal sehen, so die amerikanische Meinungsfreiheitsäußerungsgeschichte ist ja jetzt auch nicht, jetzt auch nicht endlos. Neun, weil wir jetzt in der Gorka-Herkogen-Peter Thiel-Geschichte gesehen haben, ist ja auch da die Meinungsäußerungsgrenze halt relativ hart gezogen. Nämlich genau da, wo es darum geht, Dinge über Menschen zu offenbaren, die sie halt nicht offenbart haben wollen. Diese diskussion müssen wir jetzt aber führen. Die sind hart, die sind wahrscheinlich sogar verletzend, die müssen wir aber jetzt irgendwie mal langsam irgendwie in die Gänge bekommen. Und ich würde mir halt wünschen, da halt einfach mal mehr Debatte reinzubekommen und weniger eBay mit denen spiele ich nicht, weil irgendwie die haben ja immer irgendwie Martin Schulz die Hand gegeben, irgendwie Zeugs. Also da habe ich irgendwie auch keine Lust mehr drauf. Das ist mir irgendwie zu langweilig.
Ja, gut, ja, freut uns, dass ihr uns so schön zugehört habt. Ist doch ein bisschen länger geworden, als wir befürchtet haben. Zwei und halb Stunden.
Geht schon.
Ja, na, das geht immer.
Alles klar.
So klar, so lange können wir gar nicht aufnehmen, dass es Beschwerden gibt, dass es zu lang war.
Sollten wir eigentlich auch mal probieren. So eine Philipp Buster Sendung. Na gut, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Wenn ihr uns weitere Sendungen finanzieren möchtet oder versüßen möchtet, dann gibt es bei uns einen Flitter-Account und einen Patreon-Account.
Genau. Dann wünschen wir euch ansonsten frohe Feiertage und bis zum nächsten Mal.